- You have officially two weeks left
to get dripped out.
- It's time to drip.
(laughs)
- Get your Apari merch right now
using that link in the
description down below.
If you wanna get dripped
out like us, the boys,
and get your official
Trash Taste/Apari merch,
now is the time to do, 'cause
you got two weeks left.
- Look at them, look
at them, stand up boys,
stand up, stand up.
They're actually color
coordinates this week.
Look at that, look at that.
(laughing)
- How do I look boys?
- [Joey] We have the bright
ones, we have the dark ones.
- I actually liked, I
don't wanna take it off.
- You Trash Taste or Trash
Taste after dark, you decide.
Look how fucking cute this design is guys,
and that too, and that too.
- [Garnt] It's so adorable.
The embroidery is super high quality.
- Look, the cat sleeping
is such so adorable.
I remember when I first saw
this, I needed to get this.
- Also Apari did such a great job,
because it looks like our sets.
- Yeah, it actually does.
- It's crazy.
- One for one, it's crazy.
- Last time, we had a print design,
but this time we went for embroidery
'cause we want this merch to last.
It costs a little bit more
than our previous merch,
but we want this merch to
be around when you are 90.
- Exactly.
- So your grandma who is
90 there can stand by.
(laughing)
But then seriously, the
merch is super high quality
and it will last.
So when you get it, you get it for life.
You become one of the boys for life.
- Exactly.
- Unfortunately, the first
thousand special postcards
have sold out but you will still get
a personalized message on your postcard
when you purchase one of these.
- But again, you only have
two weeks left ladies and gentlemen.
- Two weeks.
- [Garnt] Two weeks.
- So go down to the link
in that description below
and grab them while they last
because until 2022, these will be around.
But after that, it's all gone.
- You better end 2021 on a high.
Back to the episode.
- I get it too.
- So there is gonna be a couple of things
in this figurine special episode
that we won't be able to show on You Tube.
- We will hentai figures.
- Yeah, we did and--
- And more.
- And a lot more.
A lot more like craziest shit
that you're about to see
or hopefully not see.
So if you would like to see
the full uncensored version
of this episode and
support us in the process,
then make sure to go over to our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Link is in the description below.
But, yeah, if you're on Patreon,
you can enjoy this in full.
If you're on YouTube,
you can still enjoy it,
but just without the good feeling.
- The few little things will be different.
- [Joey] Just a few things might be wrong.
- Overall, it's the same shit, all right.
So don't leave.
- You just get less pixels, that's it.
- You got less pixels basic.
- That's it.
- But go over to patreon.com/trashtaste,
link's in the description
and enjoy the episode.
(upbeat music)
- Boys, before we start, we have to...
(can squashing)
Bubbling.
- A sepal.
(can squashing)
(shouting)
- Figure Special version two is now live.
(mumbling)
(laughing)
- So you got yourself
where we can completely just
not interrupt you there Connor.
- Figure Special, vigor special,
(laughing)
figure special is happening events away.
- Vigor special.
- Everyone's been waiting for it,
it's the Figure Special version two.
- That's why we're
cracking open a cold one.
- Let's fucking go.
- 'Cause it's finally here.
- A year in the making.
- We had to wait more than a year
because we had to wait
until Akihabara opened up,
people getting vaccinated,
and the country letting
us finally do this.
- Not even a global pandemic can stop us
from wasting our money on anime figures.
- Well, cheers boys.
- Cheers to a successful launch.
- Cheers, cheers, cheers.
How's it feel to be in
presence of a winner?
'Cause that's gonna be me today.
- Honestly, I'm here for the content.
I can't wait to show you some
of the stuff that I bought.
(laughing)
- Garnt, stop being a good sportsman
for one second and talk trash, alright?
- Or no, that's how you lose.
Haven't you learn from the first version?
- So if you don't know,
there are three videos on
our own respective channels
where we went to Akihabara
and spent $30,333 each,
a total of $10,000 between
the Trash Taste budget.
- Which is where the Clickbait comes from.
(laughing)
- Don't say that.
- Then I go like, "We can
stretch this out to $10,000
so we can put it on the video title."
- And we have various
challenges at those stores
that we hopefully completed
and we'll talk about
on this episode of the podcast.
- But we have no idea
what each other bought.
We don't know how many challenges
we've completed and yeah,
today is the day where we gonna find out.
- We have an idea about
what the other boys did
but if you wanna find out
now before you watch this,
then please go watch all of our videos
or you can watch this first and then go
and watch the videos,
it kind of like watching
the "Avengers: Endgame"
and then watching "Ironman."
- Either way, either
watch all of them now,
or watch all them after.
I would say watch all of them
before, but that's just mine.
- Yeah.
- But they're all up right now,
and they're all down in the
description, so check them out.
But I guess--
- And also on our main channels,
not our second channels.
- Yeah, on our main channels.
- So basically, we're gonna
just kind of, I guess,
run through the products,
where as also, overarching challenges.
Joey, do you have them?
All of the challenges
that aren't for the store
that for after the store.
- [Joey] They are onscreen right now.
We're not gonna read them all out.
- [Garnt] We have 16 of them there.
- We have 16 on them but I think
what some of the notable
ones that we remember
are like stuff like,
buying a figure closest
to the price of 420
and also 69 as well.
- Very nice.
- Of course. Of course.
I'll be honest.
I don't remember much
of the other challenges.
- I don't either,
so it's going to be
interesting if we are like
by coincidence it's figurine.
- I remember that in the first door,
I completely forgot we
had overarching challenges
and it was only in the second store
that I started to figure out.
- Well, we all tried to
go for the $69 one, right?
- I think we all tried
for the 69 and 420, yeah.
- Yeah, that was interesting.
- It's a lot harder than I thought it was.
- Yeah, so how did you boys
feel going into this challenge
compared to last year's challenge?
- I mean, my challenge is
that I go to each store
were way easier than
last year, which is good.
So I think I have a
better chance this year.
It's really up to you guys, really.
I think Garnt there got
some of the harder ones this year, right.
- I just kept getting
fucked this year, man,
which is why I was like, you know what,
I'm gonna go for the concert.
- First time?
First time.
(laughs)
It's how I felt last year.
- And this guy got an easy
road again for most part,
for the most part I think.
- [Joey] Of course.
- I had hard challenges.
I had to find a figure from
an anime Jerry I had watched.
D'you hard that is?
I had more luck finding
the needle in the haystack.
(laughing)
Like what do you...
I had this whole store full of anime
and Jerry hadn't seen a single one.
- I think it was interesting though,
because we went to four
stores again this year.
Two of them were ones that
we've been to previously,
which was Astop and Army Army.
- Yes.
- And then we had two brand new ones,
which was Lashinbang and Mandarake.
- Yeah.
- And I think the new stores
were definitely a challenge
because definitely
weren't used to it.
- Yeah, because one,
it added some spice into the mix
because we didn't know what to expect
so especially ending on Mandarake,
it was so much risk came
into what was in Mandarake,
because I hadn't been to
Akihabara for about a good year.
- Yeah.
- So I literally had no ideas
what would be in any
of these stores, right?
- Yeah, Mandarake is truly like
the needle in the Haystack store,
where like you go in...
It's the Don Quijote of fucking figures.
- I've found the coolest
stuff in Mandarake.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah.
- You've also gonne find a
lot of stuff in Mandarake,
so it's either all.
So, I'm glad we had some variations to us.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Absolutely.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- There was a store that sold everything.
Some stores, they didn't sell anything.
(laughing)
And some stores had a lot of
lewd stuff, so that's good.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- But I mean, I was kind
of nervous, kind of wasn't.
It was weird because this time
I wasn't thinking about decorating
as much as I was winning.
(laughing)
I was like, I don't care
about decorating the office,
fuck that, it's all about winning.
- By the way, if you're
brand new to Trash Taste,
the figures that you see on the backseat
are the stuff that we got last year.
- Yeah.
So we only had a budget of $500 last time,
and it got us all these.
So we like--
- We was at six times the budget,
seven times the budget, six times.
- Six top of the budget.
- I almost believe that the saying
of constraints make the what, the what?
What did you say Garnt?
- I was like, I had sex, sorry.
(laughs)
- This man. This man is the oldest one.
- That's why I tried to not say that,
and instead I said, six times.
(laughing)
- I almost having no limitations,
well, there was limitations,
The money was...
$3,000 is a lot.
- It's more than one
person will ever spend.
- So I felt like having no limitation
nearly on what you could
spend almost made it harder,
because you felt like, okay,
I can buy literally anything.
Like this before, it was
like you see a $500 figure,
there was a lot of, "I can't buy that."
- [Garnt] That was my budget.
- Yeah, exactly right, you can't buy it.
So it almost made it more interesting.
- Now, you look for them at like,
the most expensive figure in the store.
And you're like, okay,
this is like a sizeable
chunk in my budget,
but I'm not gonna be dead in
the water, even if I buy it.
- Yeah, let's just say we didn't find
a $3,300 figure that we just signed.
- There was some stuff in Mandarake.
- Oh, in Mandarake yes.
- There was definitely like one figure
would have gone our entire budget
but for the most part,
it definitely felt like a big difference
from last year to this year, right?
Because, last year, like it's a difference
between like being a student
and having a disposable income.
That's what it felt like, man.
- Just thinking about some
of the fucking figures
I had spent money on.
- [Joey] Yeah I know.
(laughing)
- No, because I remember last year,
I remember going to a store like Astop,
I was looking at figures and like,
I can't buy that, I can't
buy that, I can't buy that.
And now this time going
into Astop, I was like,
what can I buy?
Let me just buy it all.
- Even if it's expensive--
- [Garnt] I'll take your entire store.
- Yeah, it was like, I'll take
everything from here to here.
And it's like a dent in my buzzer.
- Trash Tastes season one
versus Trash Taste season two,
the peasants versus the kings.
- What's next it's like who can buy out
all of these stuff first.
(laughing)
- Yeah I actually like got to a point
where we got to Mandarake,
and I had trouble finishing my budget,
because there was like...
Mandarake had some
really, really cool shit
but the really, really cool
shit was too expensive.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then some of the mid-range stuff
didn't even make up the budget I had left
because originally--
- It was like no in-between.
- Yeah, originally I thought
we had $3,000 expense.
And then only halfway through
that I realize, oh no,
the entire budget was $10,000.
So technically, it's $3,233.
So I had to make up $300 more,
which I didn't think I had in Mandarake.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So, yeah, it was
overall very interesting.
- Yeah, it's very tough.
- Yeah, it was a long day as well, my God.
- Yeah, it was definitely
a long day for sure.
- It was great, it was great fun though.
I really enjoyed it.
- I really enjoyed it.
- I really enjoyed it too.
- Is it exhausting having to
run around stores for hours,
a little bit,
but it's not nothing I haven't
done before in season one.
(laughing)
- Exactly, I definitely felt
a lot more comfortable filming this one
than I did in season one.
- Yeah, you seemed like you're
kind of digging it more.
- Yeah, I remember when we
were all filming our intros,
I had to get away from a Garnt
because it was actually being too loud.
- Garnt is `really like Morgs now.
He's like, what's up guys?
It's me, Gigguk.
- I'm going to spent
24 hours in Lashinbang.
- He's gotten too good, he
should be upgraded to movies.
(laughing)
- The flash back to season one,
Occupant Special and Garnt's like,
"How do I sushi without a script?"
- 'Cause I remember when we
were still filming season one,
you boys had finished for like
a good 10 minutes filming your intros.
- Yeah.
- And I don't think I'd
even started filming,
'cause I'm like, "Cindy,
am I looking good?"
- Jumps of in the hood and kind like,
"What is anime?
(laughing)
"Anime is some..."
And I'm like Garnt, Garnt.
(laughing)
Just talk Garnt.
- The glow up, man, it was great to see.
- We all did a much better job, actually.
I think we also have a
confident (mumbling) experience.
How hope that came across in the videos.
Hopefully they look better,
they sound better and the energy is there.
- Yeah.
- Well then most of the
time I did get distracted
and I was so focused on doing the things
that I forgot to actually talk
to the camera all the time.
I was just so intent on focusing
on finding these god-damn figures,
that I didn't think to present very well.
I would like to hear, even
though they're too long,
I would like to hear all of
the overarching challenges.
'Cause I forgot about them
- [Joey] Oh, sure.
- I think it'd be good for the viewers
to know what challenges to keep in mind
that might come up when
you start reviewing.
- So these are the ones
that were separate--
- [Garnt] So tell us how much points
you get from them as well.
- Okay, so one point to whoever spends
the closest to $3,333.33
which is the budget.
One point, to whoever buys the
most expensive single figure.
The one with the cheapest
figure however, loses one point.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- Figuring from the lowest
rated Mal Series gets one point.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- The most figurines bought
overall gets one point.
Most spent on one series gets one point,
most spent on a non-figure gets one point,
most spent in one store gets one point.
So there's lots of room to wiggle.
- Okay.
- As we said earlier,
whoever spends the closest
to $69 on a single figure and
whoever spends closest to $420
on a single figure get one point each.
- We're counting that as
6,900 Yen or 442, 000.
- Yeah 442,000 Yen.
Figurine from the highest
rated Mal series however,
loses a point.
That's the normie point you lose.
If anyone bought a hentai figure,
that's a point because, God forbid,
you're going against
You Tube monetization.
- I totally forgot we had that.
- I totally forgot to have that too.
- I've just remembered what I bought.
(laughing)
- [Connor] Me too.
- Let's just say someone
got a point for that.
One point to the most figures bought
from an anime original movie.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- So, any like Shinkai movie, Hosna movie,
anything like that.
Minus one point for every
Funko Pop, obviously.
duplicate character anyone buys,
and minus two points
for every exact duplicate
figure anyone buys.
- Oh, I see.
- So we made that like stakes
high because it's like,
we might, say for example,
Garnt and I might buy an Astolfo figure.
We will loose a point but does--
- Joey's a massive Astolfo fan.
- Of course, but there's lots
of Astolfo figures, right?
With from different makers,
so if it's the exact same,
which I don't think will happen, honestly,
from the massive budget we
had, then it's two points lost.
And then the final one,
is if you fail to spend
at least a minimum of 50,000
Yen at a store or $500,
you'll lose a point.
I think that was the one we were all
kind of paying attention to,
because I use that as
like a good way to gauge
the rest of my budget.
- Yeah, that was to encourage us
not to hoard all our money for one store.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, and if it didn't make it clear,
the how we are converting,
we're gonna be saying
everything in dollars
but that's just basically
taking the Yen price
and dividing by 100.
- I know that 1 Yen equals $1.
It's not exactly right, but, yeah.
- Yeah, that's as close as we can get.
- It's the closest you can think of it.
- I guess we should start
with the first store then.
- Yeah.
- Lashinbang.
- So the first door was Lashinbang,
which is what we wanted to
go to last year as well,
but unfortunately we couldn't
get approval one time.
This year, since we knew--
- We plan ahead.
- Yeah, yeah, okay, huge
shout out to our Geeks +,
for actually sorting this out.
Last year, Mail-in sorted it out
in like five days or something
before we were gonna film.
This time, they had a bit more time,
but everything went smoothly and--
- Like three weeks or something this time.
We learned our lesson.
- Unlike most of the stores,
a lot of the stores we went to,
we got to have free reign over them
without our customers
which was fun as fuck.
- Yeah, Lashinbang was great especially
because we got to go in
before the store even open.
So it was two whole floors to ourselves,
we were just like...
- It's just like going to
Legoland without anyone there,
it was like amazing
- Yeah, it was like
fucking awesome, I loved it.
- The younger means dream.
- Yeah, honestly.
And that you've lived
out the dream finally.
- I've lived this dream.
- This is a natural dream, right?
Like this is the shit you
wake up as a kid being like,
I have infinite budget
to spend in this store,
and I can buy anything.
- And you have to buy a figure
that we chose for your
model store's, Connor.
It's great.
- Yeah, it's brilliant.
- Do you guys remember
what your challenges were for this store?
- Yeah, I remember.
- So, we each got
two challenges for this one.
- I remember I got fucked immediately.
So, we actually knew what challenges
were in Trash Tastes can.
Do we have Trash Taste can? Is he...
Sorry, will you...
I kept calling him Trash Taste.
- I kept calling him Trash Taste as well.
- Trash box, trash boxes.
So we actually knew the
challenges this time.
'Cause we didn't know them last time,
and we picked some easy challenges
and some harder challenges that
would be harder to complete.
- You just killed trash box (mumbles)
- My God, hillside.
- And I started off with some
of the hardest challenges.
- What were your challenges Garnt?
My challenge was one,
find an anime figure or find a figure
from a game that Connor has played.
- I play little games.
- Now, normally, this would be easy.
We're talking about Archi Harper,
famous for selling anime figures
and maybe Jay RPG figures.
You know, a lot of Japanese IP.
(laughing)
- Mostly games that Connor
has not so well identified.
- In every store, there's
multiple games that I had played.
So if you've gotten this at
any store, you've been fired.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- If you pay attention (mumbles)
- There was a lot of turn--
There was a lot of turn-based RPGs,
a lot of story-based games
that I went through.
And then my second chance challenge
was find the most expensive
figure in the store and buy it.
- Oh yeah that's right.
- If these boys found the
more expensive figure, then--
- You don't get the point.
- Then I don't get the point.
- Easy, that's right.
- And when we go to your challenges Joey.
- My two challenges were fairly easy.
So my first one was buy a Jojo figure
and make the same pose.
And I mean, you know, Jojo
figures are everywhere,
especially when she wants,
so that was an easy given.
The second one, I had to kind of
use my thinking cap a little bit.
It was, I had to buy a figure
that can beat Goku and I have
to not only buy the figure,
but I have to convince these two boys
that this character can beat Goku.
- I'm the audience.
(murmurs)
- I think I figured it out though.
- I think I figured it out.
I won't be easily impressed.
In fact, I might even be
argumentative, (mumbling).
- Wow. t's almost like I'm on Trash Taste.
- My two challenges were
buy a non anime figure,
which was very difficult.
Which is tough in Lashinbang.
- Yeah, it was 'cause a lot of the games
either had anime or animations
and I knew that you
guys would be dick heads
and that if I bought
something that wasn't anime,
but had some animation,
you'd give me shit.
And there were shorts that
I thought didn't have animes
that apparently are getting animes.
And I thought (mumbles).
And the other one,
was just pick a figure blindfolded.
- [Joey] Oh wow. Okay.
- So I'll just spin around in one section.
- So that was not tough,
it's just, it could end up very badly.
- [Garnt] It did end up great.
- Okay.
- It did not.
- It didn', we will see.
- Okay, we will see them.
- All right guys.
So like, how many figures did
you guys buy in Lashinbang?
- I bought...
- Three, three.
- All right. Same here, three.
- Okay.
- We started things off, like for me,
Lashinbang had so many
good figures, right,
It had a lot of high-quality figures,
and aside from Mandarake,
it actually had the most expensive figures
that I could find.
- Which I did.
- Which fucks me over, obviously.(laughs)
- Well, on that note then go on.
What is the most expensive
figure you purchased?
- We'll go. We'll go.
We'll go for that last.
- Okay.
- So we don't know any of the figures
that each other have bought.
I got glimpses of one
or two, but I overall,
I don't know what you guys purchased,
and I hope that you guys
don't know what I boght.
- Not gonna lie, 'cause Lashinbang
so early in the morning
and I was still late in
the waking up process.
- I don't remember half the shit I bought
at Lashinbang.
- For I, I bought three,
so it was really easy.
- For me, at Lashinbang,
I spent all of my time trying
to complete my challenges, right.
So I like, I didn't even
consider the overall challenges.
I even forgot that we
had overall challenges.
'Cause I was just trying to...
I used up all of my time
completing every all my challenges.
'Cause I remember the
store was like opening up
to general public and I was rushing
to get my figures onto like--
- You rushing man.
(laughing)
Of course not funny.
Malin laughed though.
- Of course Malin would laugh.
I remember Joey looking
at me and he's like,
"Oh Gigguk, you haven't
got your figures yet?"
And I'm just like, "No,
I'm paying for them now."
- 'Cause I can play my
challenges in like 10 minutes.
- [Garnt] Yeah, mine were pretty easy.
- And the rest of the 50
minutes, I was just perusing.
- Because both of them had
me looking around a lot.
So the second challenge,
which I did second,
which was after perusing
around to try and find
the most expensive figure
was trying to find a figure from a game
that Connor has played.
- Well, why don't you tell the story
while introducing the figure?
- Yeah. Okay.
- Well, which one do you think it is?
- Okay, well, I'll tell the story
'cause the figure is not
actually that big, right.
Because I had the most
expensive figure challenge,
I'd try to go on a budget at this point,
because it was the beginning of the day,
and so I look around,
I look around at what figures
are available on Lashinbang.
I look around,there's Final Fantasy, nope.
Connor is definitely
not play Final Fantasy.
(mumbles)
Is it really?
- It does it.
- [Connor] Have you
played Final Fantasy VII?
No, you haven't yet.
- I haven't finished it.
So I wouldn't count that.
- When.
- Wait, the remake?
- No, the original.
- What?
- You've played the
original Final Fantasy VII.
- I got like 10 hours in and I quit.
- What? What?
- Eight years ago?
(laughing)
- I actually don't believe you.
- How have you never
mentioned this before?
- 'Cause I didn't finish it.
- But you've played it.
- Yeah, I've played it.
- You know the basic concept of it.
- Yeah.
- Why we never talked about this?
- 'Cause I didn't really
like it that much.
(laughing)
- Wait, so you've owned a PS one.
- No, no it's on steam.
- So you've played it in your adult life.
- When I was like 18.
(laughing)
- What?
- I used to go on like
steam cells all the time.
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
I was literally the first
figure I saw and I--
- That was the first figure I saw.
- So if you bought that
out of enlightened,
I didn't beat it, I didn't beat it.
- But you played it.
- Yeah, I played it.
It doesn't say you needed to beat it.
- Oh, true, (mumbles)
- So like mostly I looked
around on the second floor
and I didn't notice that
there were Arknight figures
on the second floor until people
had told you about it.
- Oh really.
- Yeah. I don't know, 'cause--
(mumbles)
had such little time
that I spent so much time
trying to buy the most expensive figure
that I just like lost all my time.
So I didn't see any Arknight figures.
And then I went downstairs because
basically all of the second floor
were like expensive gaming figures,
which are just like basically
fate and find a fancy,
which I didn't know that you played.
So that was great.
- I haven't played Fate.
- Yeah, I know you haven't played Fate.
So I go downstairs and
I don't really see much.
It's again, it's mostly anime figures.
And then I see a shelf
and it's all persona.
And I was thinking...
I was say to myself,
I've been trying to convince Connor
to play Persona for two fucking years.
And it has led up to this point
and I was pissed that Conner,
if you were a good friend,
you would have taken my recommendation
and started playing Persona 5, but no.
- One time I played Persona in your house
for like 15 minutes.
- Does that count?
- I dunno if that counts.
(laughing)
- I just saw Garnt be like.
(shouting)
- Oh shit, we did, we
were very intoxicated
and that's why...
That's the only time I
remember you guys, I mean--
- Wait, wait, wait, what can you even do
in Persona 5 for 15 minutes.
- Well, what happened was is that,
I was watching Sidney
go around some like...
It looked like a digital
maze or something.
- A Mentos?
- No, no it was one of the Dungeons.
- All the way to dungeons, right.
- Yeah, I was like, give me the control.
I'll do it, a loss. And
then I got lost too.
(laughing)
So it didn't really help.
That's what I get 20 minutes.
So technically, I have played Persona.
I haven't played it
much, but yeah, (mumbles)
- But then the third one
I saw was a Mega Man one
and I've kind of never
talked about Mega Man before.
Have you ever heard him
talk about Mega Man?
I've talked about Mega Man on the show
and I don't think he was like--
- He's never mentioned it,
but like I saw Mega Man,
and I'm just like Mega Man seems
like a Connor game, you know.
It's like, I could see Connor
playing Mega Man format.
- It is a platform,
and it's a shooting platform.
Like she used to speed run Cuphead, right?
So it's like...
- Yeah, yeah exactly
but I didn't know if...
Did you want a Nintendo, what
is your game console history?
'Cause this made me question
what your game console history was,
'cause I'm like,
you haven't played Final Fantacy
because you don't own a PS one.
- I did a Nintendo 64--
- For the Nintendo 64.
- My parents took it away
'cause they thought games were evil.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I managed to convince
them to get me a PS one.
I broke it, then I got a PS two
and I got a game cube and a week,
then the next box and now PC.
- Most of the mainline consoles.
- Yeah, so I remember,
so I didn't think Connor
would be old enough
to have a Super Nintendo or Nintendo.
And like where else you play megabyte
apart from the old school concerts, right?
- Pretty much.
- So have you played Mega Man?
'Cause I didn't get it.
- Not like fully, I've played it at like,
like friends house, for like a few,
like I've never like committed
to sit down and be (mumbles)
- It is a very good like--
(mumurs)
- I would say, no, I haven't.
You asked me, I'm like...
- If I got the figure now,
and I'm just like Connor,
it's a Mega Man figure.
- I wouldn't even tell that story,
I would be like no, I haven't played.
(laughing)
Because I wouldn't (indistinct).
- 'Cause I remember Connor was like,
"I'm an X-Box kid."
And I'm like, "Okay, X-Box game Kibera."
I'll stretch it out and
say, maybe he had a X 64.
(murmurs)
And then Sydney came into Claude Shannon
was just like gone,
how can you forget literally
the most successful franchise
in the fucking world?
- I don't know what you talking about
- How can you forget the one
that's literally right
in front of your face?
Literally the most successful
franchise in the world,
and it's a tiny figure, 'cause I...
It's a figuritive figure, okay.
- What the fuck is this?
(laughing)
- Is it the anime or lady?
- 220 years.
- I know I got this.
Not forgetting that whoever
gets the least expensive figure
loses the points.
I might have just fucked myself over
by owning a point and then losing a point.
Otherwise I would've got
something more expensive.
- Maybe you should keep track of that.
'Cause that might very
much be a contender.
- Yeah.
- Okay, that's fine.
That's okay for you.
(murmurs)
- Definitely fine.
- I mean, I know you've played Pokemon,
we've talked about it several times
and even if we'd hadn't talked about it,
I could like...
You could bring this to
like 90% of anime fans
or just people in general.
They probably would have played Pokemon.
- Those were like Cyberpunk, Overwatch,
a bunch of other actual things.
- Was there Cyberpunk?
- There was Cyberpunk, yeah.
- Was that the one on the
first floor or second floor?
- Second floor.
A lot of the games were
actually on the second floor.
- Yeah. Also, I mean, Connor
found a bunch of Apex figures
at Army Army.
- I saw at Army Army at Apex figures.
- Congratulations on completing
your first challenge.
- Thank you.
- You got it.
- What a buildup.
- I just wanted to tell
you the entire story.
- All right, well I'm gonna
speed run my first one,
'cause you know, I got the points.
- Does it have no story?
- No story.
I walk in, I turn the corner,
first thing I see is a Jojo figure.
- [Conner] Who is in there 'cause I...
- Ooh.
- Okay, young Joseph.
- Young Joseph.
- It's a lottery figure.
- It's a lottery.
It's a prize lottery
figure of Joseph Joseph.
- That's a nice figure.
Let me see that, let me see that.
- Ooh, that's good.
I was going to say, I also
bought Jojo figures from here
and I was hoping you didn't
get the same character as me.
- Yeah, I hope not, otherewise,
we're going to lose a point.
- Who knows Joey.
- But I did that, all
good. Here goes Joseph.
- Look at this.
- Yeah, it's really cool.
- Are we unboxing these stuff?
- I actually want to.
- Oh, we can make them.
- Let me unbox this peek at you figure.
(laughing)
- Careful now. That's
a lot of (indistinct)
- These are a pain in the
ass, one trip from the bulk.
So now you gotta be a
for like five minutes.
- But at the same time,
since we brought on that whole thing.
- I'll open the box.
- Since we got on the topic Persona 5,
I'll show you my Persona 5.
- [Garnt] Oh my God.
- There you go.
- Hell yeah, okay.
- I couldn't not get this,
because I for one, I mean, Perona 5
is my favorite full time.
- [Garnt] We should crack this open.
- You should we crack this one open?
- Yeah. How much was this one though?
- This was... Let me see.
- So here's the question.
Would you have considered
buying this figure
if this was last year?
'Cause this was like 82 bucks.
- Yes, so the Joseph one is 8,250.
It's a $82.
- Yeah.
- And this Persona one is $200.
- Oh, okay, it's still the one.
- It's still $100, it's really big box
for what doesn't look like
it should be this big.
- Yeah, right.
But this is the Persona 5.
The animation Persona 1 ,
it was technically an anime figure.
- [Garnt] Crack it open.
Let's have a look at this figure box.
- Let's check it out?
- What's the difference between Persona 5
the animation figures and--
- It's that main character,
his name is Amamiya Ren.
- Oh.
- Where as in the game he had no name.
- Where as in the game,
he's whatever name.
- He's main character.
- He's main character Connor.
Yeah, he's Joe Cocoon.
- We live in a society.
(laughing)
- Sorry to any audio listeners this week.
- Plastic game a sepal.
- Why did you get the most
plastic thing on earth Joey?
How many turtles are
gonna die for this figure?
(laughing)
- All right.
- Maybe you're gonna have to like help us
in not being Ashley.
This is gonne be the big difference
between last year and this year,
is that now we have a hopers.
- Oh shit, (mumbles) start
tearing that apart, the glasses.
- [Malin] You guys wanna keep the boxes?
- Not my glasses.
- Yeah, we wanna keep the boxes.
- Ooh. Okay. Okay.
- That's a clean Joseph.
- That's clean as fuck.
- Yeah, right?
- So was this the pose
that you did outside?
Oh my God.
- No, no, I did I did
the standard Joseph post.
- Oh, okay.
- It just said do a Jojo pose of that.
- Do your Jojo pose, okay.
I thought he said do the same Jojo pose,
and I'm just like, I don't
think Joey would do did pose.
- I think I did this pose like every time
we booked to the store.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
Is it on camera? Is it on camera?
- I guess Joey...
- Are you sure you wanna
talk about specifics?
It's not gonna come to
bite you in the ass.
- And those specifics
will bite me I the ass.
- Okay.
- We're being nice Joey.
- Yeah.
- I would just watch
your back if I were you.
Okay, so this one's got
like a full, like...
Ooh shit, 'cause this ones
go like a full chaser.
- Joseph is very top heavy.
He's kind of like (indistinct)
where you like you ooh, he's...
- Let me have a look
at this Jojo everyone.
Joey sets up this Persona
One and this is back.
Oh, this is quite the nice figure.
I wonder why it's...
Okay, the thing with Jojo figures
is I've learned, as basically
a Jojo figure expert,
this fucking point,
Jojo figures are weirdly
expensive sometimes.
I've bought some,
so there's a certain line of Jojo figures.
I don't think of that impressive.
The visually they're not
that appealing, I'd say.
And some of the most
expensive Jojo figures
as you all see, 'cause
actually bought some
of the pucks off.
It's weird and I don't really get it.
So I guess it's strange.
But this one, normally
when they're like this,
they're pretty good.
The ones that move for some reason,
are like triple the price.
So if you've got like
the shit of ocean of this
and it moved, it'd be $200.
- It's just like, hi I'm Generic
main character right now.
- Yeah, there you go. There's Amamiya Ren.
- My brain isn't working.
- Are we keeping all the figure or...
- Bruh, that cost $80.
(laughing)
- Sorry.
- [Conner] Garnt.
- There we go. There we go.
It's so top heavy.
- He's built like a brick shit ass,
he's Jospeph mother fucking joster dude.
- I got to say he's--
- [Conner] He's holding glasses.
- He's stand is very, very big
compared to the figure.
- Like the circumference of the stand
is a very big.
- All right hold on.
- There we go.
- Who did you first
romance in Persona 5 Joey?
I don't think I've ever
talked to you about this.
- Obviously the best girl, Makoto.
- Hell yeah, hell yeah.
Oh my God bro.
- You think I'm a play say, Futaba?
Get that shit out of here.
- Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
- Literally, okay, and I did second,
but Futaba is literally the
worst girl in any Persona game.
- Thank you, oh my God.
I say this, and like
people try to crucify me.
- People who say they
like Futaba in Persona 5
are the same people who
would go to make cafes.
It's literally the same type of person.
Yeah, that's why I called you out.
I'm trying to figure out
where the chair goes.
- Like Futaba is the type of girl
who would say pagas out loud.
You know what I mean?
Like why would I want that in my life?
(laughing)
- I don't understand these
jokes, but it's funny.
- You should play a Persona
5 and you'll understand.
- I mean, you would know,
if you played Persona 5.
- Yeah.
- Do you want--
- The chairs in front of him.
- One of my challenges or generic figure.
- Which one do you wanna do first?
- None of them.
- None of them, why?
- They're all pretty alright.
- They'll pretty all right?
- Okay, I'll do the Jolene
first one first then.
- [Connor] All right.
- [Connor] Okay.
- [Joey] Oh, Jolene, nice.
- But look at the price.
- What? It's $200 for Jolene?
Why didn't you buy a
$200 figure of Jolene?
- I didn't wanna spend
much money in the store
and I wanted to figure,
and I needed one that would
put me over my budget...
Over the 500 minimum.
- Oh, this is a Sasa as well.
They're usually like rather expensive.
So these are...
Sasa super action statues.
- [Conner] That's the one.
- You can use the--
- These ones are always so expensive
and I don't think they look as good
as the other Jojo figures.
- [Joey] I don't think they do either.
- I woun't lie,
I think that Jonathan one is
cooler than this Jolene one.
I mean, I can take you
out, but it doesn't---
- It's a bit of a pain in the ass.
- You know what it looks
like. I'm not going edit.
And this is opened and it's $200.
I don't know what this would cost.
(murmurs)
- What makes them that much price?
- It's the hype of part six.
- The hype of part six. I'm
not entirely sure of part six.
- I reckon it is--
- 'Cause you said that there were
a lot of expensive Jojo figures.
- These are the expensive ones.
- That figure line.
- Yeah, the SASA's very expensive.
- The movable figure lines for some reason
are quite expensive, but Jojo.
Maybe a figure expert could
tell me why out there.
I don't really know,
maybe it's more difficult
to design figures that move.
- It can be, yeah.
There's also a lot of like
movable parts as well I think,
that's what it is.
- But I feel like with movable figures,
I feel like the static one,
static ones actually look better.
- Generally, I've always said this,
I prefer static figures.
- I do too, I do.
- I don't wanna think about posing it,
I despise the little pieces
that you have with it,
that you can't put anywhere,
where do I put them.
- I just thought with the SASAs,
I just don't like the joints
having this light expose,
and then you look like...
It looks like an Angelo.
- It's like, whatever pose you have,
you put with the movable figures.
It's never going to be
as cool as one like this
with like a static pose.
- Maybe this one's cool because Jolene,
it comes with like her extended hands.
- [Joey] That's kinda cool.
- I haven't seen that before.
So perhaps this is quite a unique one
'cause there's like,
she has extended fingers
here, finger close the photo.
But yeah, I suppose $200 though.
- It's going down.
That's big spend, it's the same as this.
(laughing)
- Joey I know.
- Like I remember I
thought like when I first
walked into the store,
when I was doing like my most
expensive figure challenge,
I thought the most expensive figures
was gonna going to be around $200.
'Cause that's what I
could find them first.
So knowing that that's $200, I think...
- Yeah, what's what's your
most expensive figure?
- We'll get to that.
- Oh my God.
He's cock teasing us as always.
- Of course, of course.
Sure You Tube need a clickbait, right?
(laughing)
So this is the second
figure that I bought.
So this is from one of my
favorite artists, Yomu.
- Yomu, nice.
- Yeah, Yomu.
So if you didn't know,
Yomu did Miru Tights
and he has done the art for another anime
that's coming out this season, I believe,
which is a Gun Buddy.
- We shouldn't have that
on the screen for too long.
We get the Montessori.
- Oh, okay.
I didn't see the copy.
- Maybe send to that Mood On.
Yeah.
(mumbling)
- [Conner] Open it up guys.
- Okay, well I'm gonna keep
it as static as possible.
So Mood On has an easy time censoring it.
- We get it. It's a very hot figure.
- So let's see this out.
So I didn't actually know that
his characters had figures.
So when I saw this--
- I've never seen that either actually.
- Yeah, 'cause like I didn't...
Do you count this as a hentai figure?
I don't really count
this as a hentai figure.
I mean, Yomu is a hentai artist.
- If it's not from an anime
and it's inspired by like
a hentai artist, I'd say--
- But he has made...
- But he's made an anime,
Miru Tights was an anime.
- Miru Tights is anime, and
I think is Ganbare Doukighan.
- Yeah I think that's either.
- I think that's the second
one where it like focuses
on office girl workers.
And I think this is just--
- It only has these
fetishes, put straight.
- I respect it.
- What I'm saying is he has amazing art.
- Stop talking to us
Garnt, show us the figure.
- I'm trying to, okay.
- This is a...
This is going to be the first
of many lewd figures 'cause...
- You had Sydney as a camera woman.
- Unfortunately having
Sydney as a camera woman,
I'd sometimes just wonder off
and then I'd look behind me
and she just wasn't there
and she'd just be like
filming this lewd figure,
and I'm like, "Sydney, I
feel so sorry for Alan,
'cause he's got to like---"
- He's gonna see your--
- He's gonna send some most of this.
- Oh, it's nice.
- That's nice.
- That's very nice.
- Nut cherry is like
nicer than the figure.
- Holy shit.
This chair's nicer than
the one I have at home.
- Dude I want this sofa, look at that.
- Put her on.
- Look at that.
- I'll give it to you.
That's pretty fucking hot.
I like that, I like that.
- That's hot, that's hot.
- This next to the pingeon
is the funniest thing I've ever seen.
(laughs)
The lewadity of man.
- How lewd is this?
Oh, that's not too bad.
The original artist definitely (mumbles)
- When I say like, he is a fucking god
when it comes to drawing
thighs, and tights.
- It sounds like you're moving
like a stone henge asked thing
on the tail when you move that around.
- Honestly this, yeah.
- That's pretty good.
- All right nice, nice.
- Oh wait, you're not gonna
show the most expensive?
- Oh, are you gonna show that?
- Oh, you want me to show it now?
- Or we can go through all the ones.
- Because you have Jerry, by the way.
- I have two more.
So one that completed the
challenge and one extra one.
I'll show you the one extra one
'cause I think, I mean,
obviously I have to represent
the greatest animated movie anime.
- Oh, okay.
- You gotta kinda figure from a Akira.
This I think was the most expensive thing.
- Well, what was that
Conner? What was that?
- Well, you don't like it.
- No, it's fine. It's fine.
(laughing)
- Tissue also kit, (mumbles).
- Not at all.
- [Joey] You sure about that?
- 'Cause I'm pretty sure
I saw Connor's life flash
before his eyes when Joey
took that figure out.
- How did you pay for this (mumbles).
- This one, I paid a $2,275 for this one.
- Oh yeah, I didn't say how
much I paid for the Yomu figure.
I paid...
I paid, what is this? $120 for this.
- Well, that's not bad at all.
- It is pretty--
- What.
- Yeah. I paid $120 for this.
- That looks like a $300 figure.
- Yeah, I know right.
- Damn, that's really good.
- I think I got a good deal on that.
- Okay, I haven't actually
seen the inside of this,
but oh, it's one of these, right, okay.
It's like the old--
- Is it like an action figure?
- It's like an old school action figure.
- Oh, okay. that's cool though.
- Once a six.
- Yeah, I saw it, 'cause
like, you know, I...
This was at the point
where I had already bought
the Joseph one and the
one that can beat Goku,
which I'll show after.
And I was having a good time.
I was like, this is the start.
This is the first one, I'll
peruse find something cool.
And I found this and I couldn't not get it
'cause I love it Akira.
Because I was going to
buy some Akira figures
and then I kind of
realized Joey's definitely
bought an Akira figure.
- Not gonna lie,
I completely forgot about
the whole like duplicate.
So I was like, you know what?
- I forgot as well.
- Yeah, it's worth.
- Because I remember
you're the only person
who bought an Akira figure last challenge.
- [Connor] No, no, no it was me.
- No, that was Garnt. Oh, that was Connor.
- Was it you?
- Yeah, it was me.
- Okay, I just assumed it was Joey.
Where's the fucketh.
- Yeah, this is the condo one, right?
- Oh, was it you?
- I bought this one.
- Oh, okay.
- This is extravagant.
- It kind of looks like
a Kendall, doesn't it?
- It does look a little like a Kendall.
- Look at that.
- That is like an Akira Kendall.
- That is an Akira Kendall right there.
- It looks clean though.
That does look clean.
- Yeah. Let me pull it out.
- Why don't you hand it off to them
and they can assemble it.
- Sure, they can assemble it.
- They can assemble this.
- All right, what is your next one Connor?
- Well.
- What is that?
- You just fucking chuck that on Connor.
- I don't really know.
(laughing)
- What do you mean you don't know.
You bought it.
- It's native creatives
collection illustrated
by he don't need to talk it though.
- Why does that name sound familiar?
- Well, Gi, 'cause it's a hentai figure.
- So do you know what it looks like?
- I do.
(laughing)
- Did you have a look at it?
- No Garnt, because my challenge,
was to open a figure, I so
choose a figure blindfolded.
- This is the one that
you were blindfolded.
- Oh, this is the one?
- This is the one I chose blindfolded.
- Which aisle did you go into like.
- Well clearly he went to the...
- Our mailing instructor, I think...
Or maybe we both chose to go hentai.
I'm not sure.
- Yeah, look inside for it.
Can I see? Can I see?
- Fucking hell.
(laughing)
- Let me see, let me see.
All right, turn it round slowly,
so move on has an easy
time censoring this.
- [Joey] Jesus Christ Connor.
(laughing)
- [Garnt] Let's go.
If this is on the line,
that is definitely over.
- The whole thing is on show.
- [Joey] Yeah, that's a
full display right now.
- Again, I didn't choose
to get this figure.
- [Joey] Can I see that?
- I need a closer inspection.
- Oh shit. On censor it looks weird.
- [Connor] Or so it's under the desk.
- That looks so weird.
Did you do you know
what's weird about topper?
Do you know what's weird
about seeing hentai figures?
- It comes with an optional moaning face.
- An eye here. Let's go.
Did you know what was
worried about hentai figures,
it's the fact that the
fucking coochie is on sensor.
It's not pixelated as fuck
- I was like, oh yeah,
that's what it looks like.
So how much detail was there on there?
- [Connor] Way too much.
- It's a lot.
- [Connor] This is a Jenner.
I didn't buy this for you guys to...
Guys, give it back to me.
- What a bottle.
Oh, wait, this, you can take this off.
- Is that removal?
- I don't know. It looks removable.
- Well, luckily there's a desk, so close.
- That's a nice angle.
(laughing)
- That's what I'm talking about.
- I don't know what this hand is doing.
- [Connor] Guys.
- What, sorry sorry, sorry, sorry.
- Sorry, it goes on the desk.
- Don't tell me hat's how that works.
(laughing)
- [Garnt] I don't know
if that's how that was.
- On the picture is on the desk.
- [Garnt] Oh really?
- Like this.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
Sorry for the...
If you're on the Patreon, enjoy,
if you're on You Tube, sorry
that this is all blurred,
but...
- I'm wondering what this
looks like on You Tube.
Is it gonna be blurred
or is it just gonna be the black box?
- It's the black box.
- Or is it gonna be like
the white glowy thing?
Mood on choose carefully.
It's the white bars.
- I'm taking this off now.
- [Both] Yeah.
- That was $200 for all.
- Oh my God.
So you spent two, $200 for that.
Two $200 figures.
- Well, I had to make sure
I reached the 500 minimum.
- Was there nothing he just wanted to buy
out of like your own volition?
- I was so focused on the challenges
because I had one that I struggled with,
which we'll discuss next time after we--
- Money will spent, I say.
- You can this one home.
- I'll take that one home, fuck it.
- Garnt was your most expensive figure
that you purchased.
- Okay, so what was the most
expensive figure that you guys?
- No, no, no.
- You should tell us.
- You bring yours out
and then if it happens
to be more than the one
that we found, then you get the point.
- Okay, well, you know what?
I'm going to go out and say it.
(Connor mumbles)
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I know I didn't get the
most expensive figure.
So what was the most expensive
figure that you guys saw?
- Do you think-
Are you saying that the Amelia one
was the most expensive
one that you bought?
- I thought it was.
- That was $700,right.
- That's was $700, it's not.
I found a more expensive.
I actually took a photo
of it, just for proof.
- Get out your figure in the meantime.
- Yes I will.
- What the fuck Garnt?
(laughing)
- Garnt, that's not a figure.
- Where are we gonna display that?
- [Malin] Wait, you
have to go through here.
- So obviously, I had the
most expensive figure store
and to tell the story of this one as well,
so my first instinct was of course
to go to the hentai section,
'cause Sydney aside,
sometimes the most expensive
figures are the hentai ones.
- They are pricing as
we've just established.
- Yeah, yeah, as we've just established.
And I saw some for like $150,
at first, I was like, oh,
that's pretty expensive,
$200, oh, okay,
now we're getting into the territory.
250, all right. 300, okay.
And then I went into the fate section.
(laughing)
- Where dreams die.
- Because of course I did
where dreams are made.
- Where dreams are made
by Romans go to die.
- And holy shit, I found
so many good figures
and like some of them,
and like, as you're about to see
with this one I've bought,
like at which point do
we not call it a figure,
and does it become a statue?
- Bring it on out.
I mean, I see it in the corner of my eye,
but it's pretty fucking ridiculous.
(laughing loudly)
- Oh my God.
- What the fuck Garnt,
where are we gonna put that?
- So I'm gonna kind of--
(mumbling)
- Can you even see me anymore on camera?
We're over here, hi.
- So I found--
I've disappeared from the middle camera.
So I found a few fate figures.
I don't know if you could
even see me right now.
- I gone hang you gone,
over the monolith slab in front of you.
- So I found this for
500 and something bucks.
- $550.
- $550, and I was just
like, there's no way...
- Either take it off the table,
or open it Garnt.
- Can one of you guys open it?
Someone's gonna need...
I'm gonna need help
cracking that boy open.
- It is literally I really
like a fancy action boy.
- That's so cool though.
- Oh, that is pretty cool.
- It's actually like made of like felt.
- Okay, so I found that
and I'm just like, yes,
I have found the most
expensive figure in the store
and it's a figure I want.
'Cause that--
- That's not a figure.
- 'Cause that looks fucking amazing.
- That's a statue.
- That looks amazing, and
I'm like, I want this.
And then I turn the corner and I see
this Emilia figure for $700
and I'm just like fuck my life.
(laughing)
I can't buy a $550 figure
and a $730 figure at once.
So I was like,
the reason I almost ran out of time
was because I was just sitting there
with both figures next to each other,
being like, do I go for the win?
Do I go for the point?
Or do I go for my heart?
- Always the point.
- And I looked at the immediate figure
and I'm just like,
I'm not gonna make the
same mistake as Subaru.
I'm gonna go, fuck the media,
I'm going go for the thing
that's right in front of me,
and I chose the fate figure.
And you know what?
I don't regret a damn thing.
That is actually the coolest
thing I've ever seen though.
- But you also wouldn't
have got the point anyway,
if you went to the...
- Because I found one...
See, I think you should
have looked a little hotter
than the hentai section
'cause I found this one and it's a $935.
- What is that?
- What?
- Kind of, look at that.
- It's a Hayachine from a son of Avicii,
which is actually a game I've played,
and it's just like a Witch Go
on this very--
- That doesn't look like it's $900.
But it's from a very famous hentai game
and it's $935, here's the photo.
- So yeah, instead I--
- You went for your heart.
- I went for my heart and I'm just like--
- I respect that.
- And I'm just like, so guys,
like if it's like a little
too big for the studio,
like what are we doing for the figures?
What are we doing if it's
like too big for the studio?
- I think there's like a
place like behind the toilet--
- Like there's plenty
of room in the toilet.
- Yeah, there's plenty room in the toilet.
- What if it's too big for the studio?
- No nonesense.
- Then it's just like useless.
- I don't know if you see
how big the studio is?
It's pretty big.
- We can get a little pedestal
behind the back camera.
- You guys are fake
fans. You guys aren't--
(Malin mumbling)
- I think it looks cool. Is that enough--
(mumbling)
- All right, Joey, Joey,
while they're still
assembling this absolute unit,
do you wanna get out your next thing.
- My second challenge was,
get a figure that could beat Goku.
Okay, now I want you to
think open-mindedly here.
- I'm gonna think very
close minded here though.
- Fuck you.
- Surely, what is that?
So this is one of the
few Lashinbang figures
that didn't come in a box.
It just came by itself.
- You've just bought Goku.
I had no, I have not.
I bought super sane Goku black actually.
- He bought black Goku.
- I bought super sane Goku black
because canonically, he does kill Goku.
- Yeah, but so is half of
the cast in Dragon Ball Z.
- So wouldn't you say
that half of the cost
in Dragon Ball Z can beat Goku?
- No.
- He technically...
He literally fought Goku and killed him.
That means he beat Goku.
- Wait, Goku is fighting Goku.
- Yeah. So drag...
Welcome to Dragon Ball Super buddy.
(laughing)
- So without having
watch Dragon Ball Super,
I know they go to like multiple universes
and I'm gonna guess that this comes from
one of the multiple universities.
- That's right.
- But the thing is right.
- Super same black Goku,
goes to the other universe.
- Sure you answer
yourself can be yourself.
- It's not. This is the same black.
- It's Goku, right.
- No, it's still the
same black Goku shoot.
- What was the line again?
- Don't shoot, he isn't black.
(laughs)
That's it.
But he is.
- I don't know if you get a character
that can beat Goku.
He's literally character that kills Goku.
Is that not a character
that can beat Goku.
So would you say the Majin Buu
is a character that can beat Goku?
- Yeah, because he literally kills Goku.
- Yeah, but Goku comes back
and then beats Majin Buu.
- Have you maybe considered that Goku
maybe isn't all that strong.
- What are you saying? You can't say that?
- The mother fucking dies like six times.
I don't think a guy who dies
six times in his own show
is considered so that strong.
- (mumbles) So much and coming back,
how does that--
- Okay, okay. But can he beat Goku now
in the latest episode of
Dragon Ball Super, right.
Because otherwise, half of the characters,
anatomy can beat like child
Goku when he was a kid,
just because someone can
beat him at some point--
- We probably should
have been more specific
with the challenges in that case, huh?
All right, Connor, what'd
you think about this Connor?
What'd you think about this?
- I literally searched up characters
that have killed Goku
and he was the first one that came up
and I literally saw
perfectly the exact same
form as well of when he...
This is the hand that took
Goku's life right here.
- I think it's shit, but it's all right,
you can have for that fucking point.
- Thank you.
- All right.
- I don't know--
- If honestly...
- Out of my kindness.
- Dude, if this wasn't gonna pass,
I was about to fucking quit.
- Where he did it, was that the only thing
you can think of?
Was there like no other possibilities.
- See, the problem is
all the other characters
in dragon ball that have
killed Goku canonically
just don't exist in Lashingbang.
It's all Dragon Ball Super
characters right now.
- I thought you were going to
pick like a Jojo character.
Like if you would pick like, like who?
Like go and experience Requiem
or something like that,
then that'd be like, you know what?
- There's a Dragon fan out there
that has an argument against that.
- Rowan Kisha bay could be...
- Let's say that all of that is...
See, all of that is your own opinion
because you guys love Jojo
more than Dragon Ball.
But this is canonical fact.
(mumbling)
- Dragon fans, what do you think,
you have the final say,
we're gonna give him the point now,
but you have the final say
in the comments section.
If you say no to this then,
I think you should quit
being a Dragon Ball fan.
- But bring on the face statue.
- Bring the monolith.
- Holy crap.
- Oh my God.
- The structural integrity
of this seems questionable.
- That looks amazing.
- That is actually one
of the coolest things
I've ever seen.
- Holy shit. I regret nothing. Oh my God.
- I hate that It's good.
- Look at that, look at that.
- That's like a statue
you'd win at an award.
Dude, that's that's...
You know what? I'mma say it. Fuck Amelia.
(laughing)
Fuck Emilia.
- Fuck the hands off Emilia.
- Fuck the hands off Emillia.
- Every painting.
- And how do we put this?
- I don't know guys, we'll find a way.
- Well, where do we put this--
- I'm just saying though.
It's like perfect diamond by
little area behind the toilet.
- Come on, come on, come on guys come on.
This doesn't deserve to go in the toilet.
- Oh my God.
- It'd be great to look
at while I'm pissing.
- This looks even better in-person
than it even in pictures.
- It's pretty sick.
- Get this out of here.
Get this out of my sight.
- We're keeping them.
- The fuck, it's literally
blocking my camera Garnt.
- Let me look at it for just abit longer.
- It's taking up like a
quarter of the camera.
(laughing)
- It's a six figure guys, it's amazing.
- It's not even a figure at
this point. It's a statute.
- It's a statute.
- And the final figure from Lashingbang.
- Well, what was your challenge?
- I'll tell you what my challenge.
I'll tell you the story.
- [Joey] Go on.
- It was to buy a non-animefigure.
And surprisingly very difficult
'cause I thought, okay,
well, if I bought
something like Overwatch,
you'd be like, oh no,
there's Overwatch animations,
it doesn't count.
There's all this nonsense and shit
you guys would fucking be mean about.
And then I found a Terminator
figure and I thought,
oh, that'd be great.
It turns out there's a Terminator
Coming out or something.
Everything I found (mumbles)
I found some Star Wars figures.
I was like, oh fantastic.
(murmurs)
It's like they trying to
make this difficult for me.
They're trying to attack me.
So close your eyes.
(speaks off the microphone)
Truly the best figure I've ever purchased.
- That doesn't have an anime.
- Does not have an anime?
- No, it definitely doesn't.
- Check this shit out.
(laughing)
- What?
- $200, fuck.
- Where's that Fantastic Beast.
- Yeah, that is Fantastic Beast.
- Oh my God, I didn't
even know this sold this.
- Why did you sell this?
- Gala Grindelwald.
- Who's is that?
- That doesn't sound
like a real character.
- [Malin] It's Johnny Depp.
- It's Johnny Depp.
- [Garnt] It's Johnny Depp?
- [Joey] That's meant to be Johnny Depp.
- $200, is the only thing I could find,
and after I purchased it in the video,
I found a figure that
would have met the criteria
for like $1.
- What was it?
- I can't remember what it was.
It was something, I was pissed off.
I buried it in my mind.
What is this?
This fucking movie sucked.
- I haven't even seen Fantastic this year.
- I haven't even seen it.
- Oh look shit.
- [Malin] I guess...
- Why does it smell so bad?
- I guess Connor, you can
keep that one for yourself.
- No, no no, no.
You should...
(laughing)
Of course you want Grindelwald on the set.
Who wouldn't want Grindelwald,
Kellogg Grindelwald.
- What does he have Okie Jasu here.
- What's he gonna look
he's like the fucking...
- He looks like he's mid transformation
into Edward Scissorhands.
- So can someone explain
fantastic beast to me?
- It's a spinoff of the
Harry Potter series, right?
I'm pretty sure, it's the same universe,
but it doesn't mention Hogwarts
or any of its characters.
- [Malin] It's the time before.
- I hadn't seen it.
- I enjoyed the first movie along
and I was excited for the second movie.
- [Joey] Did you like
Gerald Grindelwald and--
- No, it was shit.
And the second movie was shit.
It was so bad.
And I was really annoyed,
'cause I really liked the first one,
and I'm pissed off.
- Is he only in the second one?
- He appears it like a little
bit in the first round,
but like only like it's a...
- Lot of slots. The plots are fantastic.
- Fuck off Garnt. It's complicated.
- I've never known what it's
got to do with Harry Potter.
- It's just he's the main bad guy.
- It's just in the same universe.
- That's it?
- Yeah.
- It's in the same university,
has written by J K.
- Okay.
- I can see, oh wow, his joints move.
(laughing)
- Oh, you can make him walk.
- He can get on his knees.
- You know what Connor, at
least it's not a Funko pop.
- Yeah, exactly.
You don't lose a point--
- You have to tell us.
On face, on face.
You spent $200 on the Persona figure.
Who's buying these.
- I think Johnny Depp is buying them.
Cut them in business.
- What I wanna know is yeah,
who is buying Fantastic Beast figures?
- Get this out of here.
- I'm sure there are like
Harry Potter or Tacos
out there right.
- Yeah, definitely got this out of my...
- [Malin] Dumbledore's hot.
- Don't say dumbledore's hot.
- I did my challenge.
Here's in the movies.
- Yeah. And yeah,
that was everything I
bought in Lashinbang.
- Yeah, same, how many did you buy, three?
- I bought three.
- I mean, I just spent three as well.
- I spent $578 in Lashinbang..
- I spent 500, 8000, no, $589.
- I spent $572.
- Wow, we were all really close.
Holy crap, this is Astop.
I'll never mind.
- My bad. It looks like
I just spoiled myself last time.
I spent $674.
- All right. The next store is Astop.
And this is the one that
we went to last time
and it was a fan favorite dare I say,
'cause it's quite visually appealing.
It's really cool, raeally
interesting store,
tons of figures and you
really do have to look.
So I hope you guys spent a lot of money
or bought a lot of figures.
I know I bought a lot of figures.
- Yeah, I think I bought
like in terms of pure number,
I think it's either Astop or Army Army
I bought the most figures actually.
- I actually didn't buy a lot.
- Oh, really.
First of all, what were your challenges?
- I guess so my two challenges were...
- Mine was one, to buy a female figure
and two, to buy a lewd
figure, which is great.
- That's pretty easy.
- So I could get two figures in one
and I guess I'll start off.
My figure first, I believe this is it.
So I actually...
This was the first time that I
actually tried to be tactical
about what I bought.
- For once in your life.
- In Lashinbang, once again,
we had add Reyes like last year
and this time we had like--
- Thank you for the cloth.
- This time we had the faith
figure way, you know what?
It didn't matter. It didn't
matter about the game.
I just followed my heart.
All right, so this was the
lewd figure that I bought.
So we don't get ready to sensor this
'cause I'm not sure...
I can't remember how allude it is,
I don't think it's hentai loot,
but it is definitely lewd.
Oh, and it is that girl from...
I can't remember.
- Oh, it's from...
- No it's a boring girlfriend.
- What's...
- Oh, Saekano.
- Saekano, that's the one.
So yeah, It's that girl from Saekano.
Do you want me to point
this towards the camera?
The reason...
- There's a lot of panty.
- The reasons there's a lot of panty
and from one angle it's safe.
- [Connor] The other is not.
(laughing)
- And I mean she's not putting on thighs,
but she is putting on her socks.
And so the reason I bought this one
was because he was a female figure.
It's was a lewd figure,
and it was very, very close to 420.
I'm not gonna reveal how much this was
just because I know You
Tube bought some other ones,
but yeah we'll reveal those at the end,
but I will say it is close to 420.
So that's around--
- Damn, 420 for that?
- Yeah.
- Did he go into the mahogany wood?
What's going on here?
- That kind of stuff is pretty expensive.
- That kind of stuff is pretty expensive
and I'm gonna show why.
I feel like I was surprised
that this one costs this much.
Right, because--
- It's just like weirdly popular
in Japan for some reason,
I don't know why.
- I decided to--
I decided to go for it
because I couldn't...
Looking back, I couldn't find many figures
that were close to the 420 mark.
So I like, I saw this one,
and I was like, this one's close ish,
so let's just go for this one
and see where it takes us.
- Right, right.
- Joey, which ones you were on?
- So mines were, the first one
was get a fist of the North Star Finger.
Which is perfect because
this is the North Star
was like one of my favorite
Manga series of all time.
- You are so lucky to
get this one in Astop.
Because you would have found...
- Any other store I
would have been fucked.
- If you're like, it's maybe like Astop,
and maybe Manderake, Lanshinbang, and--
- Lashingbang and Army Army I would never.
- Army Army no way,
because we chose this one because we knew,
it could be completed if
the right circumstances
were met.
- Exactly.
- But like because it's
such an old series,
it's rare to find any figures.
- It's just rare in general
to find anything physical
and all-star related.
But I go one,
you're in shock.
- Did you actually?
- Yeah, it did.
Not only that, I got a two
for ladys and gentlemen.
I got a two for one for this.
- You got two for one?
- I got two for one.
I not only got my boy Ken,
but I also got that all as well.
As a combo set, look at that.
- Oh my God. How much were.
- These?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- These were, if I remember correctly,
it wasn't actually that
expensive this one.
These were I think $148.
- Together.
- Together for the two.
(mumbling)
Yeah it's actually not bad at all.
Actually I think...
No, no, no, no.
I think this was actually
the cheapest one.
I think this was $25.
- [Connor] That's pretty cool.
- Yeah, for a twofer.
I mean, these are like kind of...
I mean the one in box for-one,
but it was a two for one.
So you start winding up like that.
- That's pretty sick.
- Hell yeah boys. The
boys are back in town.
Let's go.
- I'll just show the one that I got.
- [Garnt] Yeah, go for it.
- I got a pretty cool
looking Joetra figure.
- [Garnt] Oh, okay.
- [Joey] Oh, nice.
- From like the '90s OVA.
- [Joey and Garnt] Oh.
- I'd never really seen that.
- I love the dangly bits actually.
- Yeah, I've never seen a figure...
- [Garnt] It looks '90s.
That looks vintage.
- I went for it 'cause I
wanted more Jojo figures.
'Cause I think I didn't
get enough last time,
I wanted more on the sat and I thought
this is really fucking cool,
'cause it must've been
modeled after the old '90s
when that came out.
'Cause like Jojo doesn't
use a fucking scoff thing
in the new one.
- I'm so glad I didn't
get any Jojo figures.
'Cause otherwise I'd be losing points
left and right, right now.
- I'm glad you didn't get Joseph--
- Why does it look more like Lupin.
- Oh, a little bit.
- A little bit. Yeah. Yeah.
- I'm supposed to pick it was sick.
I think it was not that much as well
if I remember correctly.
- The problem with Astop
is that you can't actually
see which ones they were.
- That's right.
(murmurs)
- I have to remember it.
- I remember this one was quite cheap.
It was like 2000, 4000, no more than that,
pretty good.
What else you've got?
- So after I got...
After I've completed as
many challenges as I could.
I basically just...
- Oh, this was a complete,
one of my challenges
was that many of my fingers,
which is get tired from
shutting in protocol easy.
- I did what any guy would do
and just start collecting wifers.
- Very admirable, I respect that.
- I got a kid now from
a re zero season two.
I got her school uniform one, which is--
(mumbling)
Why?
'Cause the kid is cute.
I'll do, she's so cute. What the fuck.
- [Connor] Garnt, come on.
- Of course I got to choose a refigure
as I couldn't actually
find many teaser.
I couldn't actually find many teaser.
Does this count as a Funko Pop?
I just wanted to buy one,
rent a girlfriend figure because
I couldn't actually find many
and I couldn't find many reason.
I couldn't find many of Cheesery.
So I don't know if there was like,
if not enough had been made,
these were pretty cheap.
They were about in the $10 range.
- Yeah, I can tell.
- Yeah.
And I mean, I just wanted to pump,
pump the figure numbers up with some girls
that hadn't been on the shelf yet.
(murmurs)
- Okay, I bought two other
ones that want a challenge.
So the first one I got was
meets off on communal knowledge.
- Sure, I didn't see that one.
- And because one of the challenges
is get a figure that is from
an anime movie Original,
so that's one point for me.
This was actually the most expensive.
This was $258.
- Was it get the most anime figures
from the movie Original? What was it?
- [Joey] No, just one, I think.
- How about we have that challenge.
- Was the most part I remember.
- You should double-check, I'm
pretty sure it get the most.
And I think there's one from
an anime Original movie.
- Yeah wait, it wasn't get one from--
- There was two movie
challenges, all right.
- Oh yeah, most figures bought
from an anime Original movie.
- What a (laughs)
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- Well I figured,
it was gonna be kind of
difficult to find figures
of anime Original movie,
because they are quite rare.
I mean, the fact that this is $258
says that this is pretty rare.
- Why is this so expensive?
- Because I personally have
never seen a (mumbles).
- I've never...
I didn't even know that--
- Me neither.
- If we're doing anime original figures,
I will pick out my other one.
I got a pro figure. Oh nice.
- Ooh, nice.
- [Connor] Only one.
- Yeah, only one.
This one, I got a pretty decent price.
This one was...
- I thought it was quite expensive.
- I saw two, one was pretty
expensive and one was--
- I actually have both these Androids
from a primary actually.
They're really nice.
- How much is this one?
Oh, this one was $59.
- Oh, it's not too bad.
- Yeah.
I feel like anime original
figures are hard to find.
So they're normally like pretty expensive.
Alright.
What did you get Conner?
- I also got another Jojo figure,
because this one was sick.
- How many Jojo figures did you find?
That one is good though.
I actually saw that one.
(murmurs)
- I just lost the point, so did you.
(laughing)
- How did you get a DM or Jonathan?
- No. Oh wait. No, that's Jonathan, right?
- Yeah.
- Oh, okay, I thank God. Okay.
I got confused. I thought
that was Joseph for a second.
Sorry--
(murmuring)
- But he's like collecting
the entire Jojo costs.
- So eventually he's gonna get the Joseph.
- So look at that.
That's we got Jonathan and Dio together.
Like I just, I've never seen this one.
- [Joey] That is really nice.
- [Garnt] That is really nice.
- I've never seen this anywhere.
I love the light lightening
effects on the figures.
I love the light glow it's so cool.
It's just...
Everything about this
figure sake is 150 bucks,
but again, I've never
seen this figure before.
I thought it was really cool.
And I love Jojo and
everyone knows I love Jojo
so I got it from the collection
and it's a beautiful boy.
It's a beautiful, beautiful.
- Beautiful boy.
- Well, this is gonna open the ninja
cause it's a bit more finicky.
- I mean it's...
It's nice, I wouldn't say--
- You clearly know that
Tucky is supposed to be here.
- Yeah.
- It's supposed to be--
- Get on 500 total--
- 500 total on--
- Photo now.
That doesn't look worth $250.
I'm not gonna lie.
- The other one I bought was the one
that I tried to get as close to $69 with.
That was one of the challenges
and it is from one of my
favorite games, Akami.
(shouting)
- Yeah.
- That is nice.
- I love Akami, so cute. There's
a stand for this as well.
- [Garnt] We'll come to you in the end.
- I'll tell you at the end when we...
- Because it should be the same, right?
For everyone try to buy it---
- Maybe, maybe.
- I have one more. I'll
have one more figure,
which doesn't...
- I'll go five.
- Do you wanna go first?
- That's all my ones except
for my last challenge.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. I got a Sebastian Mikaela's pointy
because it was like the closest to 69.
- Okay.
I guess we'll reveal
that at the end, yeah.
- Pouring tea. I got a
bunch of other ones too.
I don't know what this is.
- Oh God. Its tea.
- He's going through like every part.
- He's actually gonna lose points
for getting all the same right.
Across the road rolling one. .
- I thought this was too good not to get.
It looked sick on the shelf.
Where does his hands go.
- [Joey] To the back, isn't it?
- [Garnt] Oh, I gues like that yeah.
- It looks pretty cool Actually.
It would look really cute on
the shelf to have a road...
- I feel like...
- That's so cute.
- I feel like Connor is
just rebuilding his set
from homeless.
- And he's actually figured it out.
I wish I had it hurts.
If you guys don't want
to have them on the set,
I'll gladly take care of them.
I thought, well, that's just so sick.
Like, oh, it's so cool.
- [Joey] Pretty simple.
- [Garnt] It's really
nice. Oh, there he goes.
Look, I stay up.
- Maybe he wants to ride
it. He wants to ride.
I got that. I got how many
more fees do you have gone?
- I have one more.
- What she say to me?
- Keep going.
- I don't know the deal--
- Oh my God.
- You don't know if you buy duplicates,
you lose points, right.
- Yeah, I know. But only one point, man.
- Wait, he's got three deals.
He's got three deals.
- It's the same character. So
it's any one duplicate, right?
(murmuring)
- I think it should work in even numbers.
- Yeah.
- So it goes like 2, 4, 6, you know?
So if you buy one more--
- Factorial?
- Yeah, yeah, so if you
buy one more deal figure--
- You know, I bought sick figures
'cause they were sick.
There was sick nasty figures
and this one is like a big chunky boy.
- Finds a Jojo figure.
That's a sick figure.
- That's a sick vigor.
That's a chunky Deo, Jesus.
- That looks like it's from the '90s.
A lot of these have looked like that--
- That face is definitely '90s.
I remember this scene from the '90s over.
- And that's why I went for it
because you don't often
see the older OVA figures.
But I feel it feel like they've
got a nicer build quality
in some ways.
- Because like, it was
Jojo wasn't mainstream.
When the '90s OVA came out.
(shouting)
- It's so big. I just
couldn't help myself.
- Big boy knocked over another big boy.
- That's a chunky boy.
- There's just as a note, our knives,
all of these are Ashley's knives.
knife, Kennesaw.
So I don't know why you
own all of these knives.
- That's a not a knife,
that's a crew nader.
(laughing)
- So that's the Deo.
I think that's pretty fucking sleek.
- That's really like...
- Oh, that's a really, really cool.
- I think that's a really cool
figure, which level degree?
I hate these stands. Which one is it?
Do we know?
- [Joey] Just give it a base.
- It's his stand.
That's a Jojo reference.
- Garnt, what's your final
figure befor I show my final one.
- All right, gentlemen,
as Joey has just shown,
you've heard of Goku black.
(laughs)
- You did not get that--
- Well, let me introduce you to...
- [Connor] You did not. You
did not get that figure.
- Oh, you didn't get that figure.
- Let me introduce you to black Goku.
(laughing)
- I was hoping one of you
would have bought this.
Does it matter? Tell
me how much you it was.
- It was...
(laughing)
How much was this? Oh my God.
Those were $60.
- That was 60 bucks?
- 60 bucks steel wool.
- What went wrong.
Who made this?
- I think, I think someone
at the factory fucked up,
clearly forgot to like paint it.
(laughs)
- Who's trying to sell unfinished figures.
- Like somebody in the
factory was like, all right,
we got the model down, perfect.
Now we've just got to apply paint.
And then there's like alriht,
it's going up tomorrow.
Like the detail is really, really good,
but he's just like, he's just sunburn.
- What happened?
- Today is sunburn.
By sunburn, you mean he
like ran into the sun,
then yeah, probably.
But like he's a chard.
That is, that actually
looks really cool though.
- It does, it does.
- Is this like a character
in Dragon Ball fighters
that hasn't been released yet?
(laughing)
- It's like a secret fighter.
is the secret fighter
we've been waiting for.
- Final boss it's like a dark link. Right?
(laughing)
- I dunno. I just saw that.
And I'm just like, I just need to buy this
just so I can say what the fuck happened.
- I mean, to be fair,
that's actually really cool.
- Really cool, but...
- Wait, hold on do I lose a point?
Because we both got to go.
- I guess so--
- Great thanks, awesome.
After all that convincing I tried to do
and I just lose the point.
All right so my second challenge
at Astop was to get a figure
from an anime that I have a researched on.
- You got Goku black, right now.
- No, no, no.
(murmurs)
- They both have character.
- [Malin] Parallel Universe,
(murmurs)
- No it's not, that is the same character.
- He's not the same character.
This is actually the Goku
that Goku black kills.
- But it's the same
character. They both lose.
- This is what happens when
you fight Goku (laughs).
- You turn into black Goku.
- We all lost a point.
We literally all lost a point.
- I actually think canonically--
(shouting)
Cannonically different characters.
(murmurs)
Actally check this.
- Yeah, check this.
'Cause that's just regular Goku.
That's just painted black.
- If he was like a Ruskin.
If I go like the view--
- I think if you asked the viewers,
they would say Goku is a Goku black--
- No, no, no.
(murmurs)
- You know that I'm right.
- We all lose.
- No, you know I'm right.
- We all lose a point.
- Actually what do you think?
- [Malin] I guess.
- No, what do you mean you guess,
that there's no carrots.
Not the same Garrison's
name. It's Goku snack.
- No, no, it's black Goku.
I bought super sane Goku black.
- No, no, no, no. It's Goku
- He has another fucking
name. He has another name.
- [Connor] No, no.
- Show me.
- No.
- It's a different character.
- It's literally a different character.
- Thank you fam.
- Thankyou Dragon Ball
Super for being stupid.
- We should ask Twitter a
poll. I think a picture.
They'll say that it's the same character.
Yeah, because you know,
if the viewers watch this,
they would say--
- But viewers don't know shit.
If we ask them Dragonball fans,
they would, agree.
- Super sane Goku black.
Totally different.
- No, it's the same.
- All right, my second challenge
at Astop was to get a figure from an anime
that I have recently watched.
- So nothing.
- See--
- So what did we count as recently.
- He said three months, right?
Which means that it has to
be either from this season
or at least last season, right?
That's three months.
- You could have watched
an old anime, right?
- I think you forget there's one
very, very, very popular anime this season
that has actually come out
that I did actually watch,
but I didn't watch it this season,
I watched it quite a while ago.
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
- That doesn't count.
- Excuse me, you go into mal
you look up anime of this season.
I'm pretty sure Demon
Slayer, McGahn, Russia
actually comes out.
- Watch it within the past three months.
- What did you buy--
- Infact I rewatched it.
- No, you haven't, have you?
- No, I have no.
- No you have not. Fuck off.
For more reason how you rewatched it
'cause I thought it was a good movie.
- No, you have not watched it.
You have not.
- I'm sorry. You guys said, look on Mel,
and if it's from this season
or last season, then accounts.
- You must have watched it
within the past three months.
- That's not what it said.
- Have you watched within
the past three months?
- What have you watched
in the past three months?
- Fucking nothing.
(laughing)
Obviously. That's why I picked this.
It's from this season,
you guys said it needed to be
from at least three months.
(murmurs)
- We said three months.
- It came out within
the past three months.
It came out within the past three months.
I'm sorry. I saw it earlier,
but it came out in the last three months.
- We literally picked
that challenge beforehand
because we knew it would
fuck you over if you got it.
And you got you somehow. Got it.
I'm say if I get the most expensive figure
challenge, Joey,
then you're going to
take the L on this one.
I'm sorry, man.
I'm sorry.
- You clearly took the L
in the most expensive one.
You literally said that came out
within the last three months.
This came out within
the last three months.
- We said, we never said.
- Well, what is the exact
wording of the challenge?
- [Malin] Figure from anime
that you've recently watched.
- Recently watched.
- If I'm an animator you've recently.
- I might as well not to have eyes either
because I clearly didn't watch anything
in the past three months.
You guys knew that, obviously,
So obviously you've
made the fucking rules.
- It's not helpful full.
- It's not my fault anime's
been fucked this year, right?
- Yeah. I know what anime
you watched recently, Beaten the Ditch.,
You rewatched it.
- No the movie
- You rewatched Riding The Ditch, right?
- That didn't come out
in the last three months.
- It literally doesn't say come out
in the past three months.
- Yeah.
- It said recently, right?
- Within the past three months.
- That's not recent.
- But you rewatched it.
- Have you watched...
- Okay, so hold on. What
was this supposed to be?
Because it said Watson
in the last three months,
but they, you guys brought
on the bull shit rule
of it needed to be,
it needed to have come out
in the last three months.
That's what you said.
- No, no, you needed to have watched it
in the last three months.
- No, no, no. I have video proof.
- You said it needed to have come out
in the last three months.
- Then you provide that.
- When you provide video proof--
- It's live right now is this episode--
- I don't see the video proof right now.
So I guess we'll have to wait for the day.
- But this came out in
the last three months.
- All right,
- Ashley, how many contentious
points do we have now?
We have the Joest.
We have the Goku black thing.
- I think most of the
points of contention.
- I think we might need to wait off.
Well, we might need to wait off
to let the audience decide
some of these points.
And then we can do like the
forfeit later than this.
- Do you know our audience?
- They're gonna do everything
they can to fuck us over.
- Well that's...
- They're not going to give us the point.
It might as well be zero points.
- Look, audience.
We're gonna make a poll and Reddit.
And we gonna ask you--
- That's the he worst I've ever heard.
That's literally the worst
idea I've ever heard.
That's the last place
I'd go to to do a poll.
- Totally gorgeous.
(murmurs)
(laughing)
- I saw about a million--
- I saw about 17 views (mumbles.)
You don't even have to take
it out of the box, man.
We know what he looks like.
- So you don't wanna see?
- No, I'm good, man.
I know what it looks like.
- Just whip of the knife.
- Out the norm potently though,
how much did you guys spend at Astop.
Because you won't actually believe this
'cause this was completely coincidental.
I literally spent 500 exact.
- [Connor] Really?
- Yeah. Look, $500 exact.
- I spent... Holy shit.
I spent $572.
- Okay, and how much did you spend Connor?
- I'm just get my Jojo.
That's it.
- He doesn't have a standard.
- No, you're like goes
on the side of a table.
- Oh yeah.
- I actually see the box.
It says noodle stopper figure.
- What does that mean?
- That means you put it
on, wait for it to boil.
- So I spent a total of $620.
- Oh, damn.
- Before we move on from Astop though,
I wanna hear the story about
what the fuck you went through
in Astop.
- I lie. I forgot a figure.
- Oh, nevermind.
- And it's my coolest and most expensive.
Do you want to carry on
with that thing though?
- No, no, go show your figures.
- Show you figures.
- Close your eyes boys.
I wanna unbox it fully before I show you.
- I think I know what it is.
- Yeah, it's the most
coolest figure on earth.
- It's the one that we all saw last year.
- What is it that last year?
(laughing)
- Is it from that one
series? I haven't seen yet?
- No, no, no, no, no. No, no, no, no, no.
- Perhaps a certain...
- No.
- I'm tired.
- I have no idea what the
fuck you talking about.
- I know serious, bro.
You're going to be...
- I saw him pick this out.
So yeah.
- You did?
- Yeah. I saw you pick that out.
- You just have spoiled this Joey.
- Yeah, so I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna open my eyes,
'cause I know what it is.
(mumbles)
This is one of the dumbest
and yet coolest figures
I've ever seen.
- This is the most epic figure,
I'm fuckung tired, I can't get it open.
Sorry, Darn.
- Really dragging this whole corner.
- Drag my nuts. All right.
- All right can I (mumbles).
- In three, two, one.
(laughing)
- What the fuck. That's amazing.
Where did you find this?
- You didn't see this?
- I didn't see that.
- It was there last year as well.
- It was $300.
- I'd say worth.
- Honestly, this is so sick.
- We were in which box would that fit in?
How did they display that?
- It was literally like.
(laughing)
- Okay.
- That's the box it comes in.
- I love this scene and hunter, hunter.
And I just, when I saw it
and I knew I had the spare budget,
I couldn't say no.
- The only reason why I
didn't buy this last year
is because it was over our budget.
- Yeah.
- It's so sick.
- I actually wish I bought it...
- I ctually wish I bought
more and they stopped
because they were more like
more cool figures that I wanted to buy,
but I didn't know how
much I would be spending
in like the next ones.
But looking back, I wish I...
There was so many figures
that I wish I'd bought.
They would like some black lagoon figures
and some cat figures.
(laughing)
- Yeah. The gowns figure.
I really wish I bought.
(mumbling)
- Yeah. But I mean, like
Astop's a cool store.
So is Lashinbang.
There was so many cool
figures and Lashingbang.
- They're at the same building as well.
- Yeah, exactly.
(laughing)
- Hey careful. This was $160.
- It's pretty sturdy.
It's that the most expensive figure.
- Oh no. This is the most.
This is $300.
It's like the flimsiest plastic
thing I have ever bought.
I'm watching it's I
imagine it's just that much
because of how pretty rare it is.
- [Garnt] I've never seen that before.
- [Joey] I've never seen that.
- I don't know where you even buy it
or when you get it from.
- It must've been available quite a while.
- Could be a collective item.
- It's just the coolest
thing I've ever seen.
- It's so ridiculous.
- I love it. I love this.
(shouting)
- This has a different
center of gravity totally.
- Honestly, it does.
(laughing)
- It's very top heavy.
- A little bit.
Kind of feeling how dumb it would look
in real life if you showed Darn,
what he was going, super sad.
But yeah, that was my art.
This is my whole.
- You got a lot of these stuff.
I mean, you mostly--
- All of it was this.
Mostly it was Jojo figures, right.
- Mostly it's three deals in a go.
- For Jojo figures, a black
ball lock potluck and a...
Pretty good thing.
- Can it beat black Goku.
- All of these can be black Goku.
- I think that's still my favorite.
(laughing)
- That's your favorite?
When we have this, Joey.
Oh, Joey. How dare you Joey.
- The thing is I sold this on last year.
I just can't believe this one's a real.
Ironically looks epic as well.
I can't get over how cool that little bit.
- Could you repeat that?
(laughs)
So we found a meme recently,
which is just like,
(mumbles) with the caption,
could you repeat that?
And it's like, you can see his
Dick just half chopped off,
- It's like the edge of
his arm on the screen.
It's the funniest thing
I've ever seen in my life.
- That was Astop.
- That was an at Astop.
Moving on, I need the toilet.
So before we move on to Army Army though,
Joey, what was this thing
about this guy buying curator figures
that I've heard about?
(laughing)
- Oh yeah, yeah.
Yeah. So when I was lining up at Astop,
there was a dude in front of me.
It's in my video as well,
but there was a dude in
front of me in like a full
on businesses.
It was like a proper Japanese salary man.
And I overheard and I thought,
I doubted myself for a second.
I overheard the words
Kirito and 600,000 Yen.
I thought, what?
- Which is $6,000.
- $6,000. And I was like,
excuse me back copy rigt?
- Did you get a glimpse?
- I leaned in closer.
I think he ordered it in bulk at Astop.
'Cause I think there was just too many.
And then I found out as I was...
He left and as I was checking out and
I talked to the dude, I was like,
the guy before me, what did he buy
if you don't mind me asking?
And he said, oh, he bought
$6,000 worth of curatory fees.
- They do exist.
- And I was like, oh my
God, they actually exist.
These types of waves exists.
So he literally went into the store
and said, I'll take your entire stack.
- I'll take your entire
stalk off the curato figures.
- Who is buying $6,000
worth of curato figures.
- So he was probably like
in his maybe mid 30s, right.
Just buying like...
I think he bought like
13 or 14 Kyoto figures.
Like so many that he
didn't even like bother
bringing them up.
I think he just gave them the paper
and said just send it to me.
- Oh my God.
- Dropped his money and then just left.
- Is this like an investment?
- Is this curator reseller?
That's the only explanation
I have for this guy.
It was insane.
- She's a big fan you know.
- I guess so.
- All right, boys what
challenges did you have
at Armyarmy.
- So for Army aArmy, we
have three challenges.
- Just want to make it a little spicy.
- Yeah.
- And we did wanna make--
- And spend a lot of money there.
- And we did.
This was probably going to
be the longest segment yet
because we bought a lot of cigars.
- My one were fairly varied.
My one was get a figure that's American
buy a Wall Scroll and
by an Incestuous series
and shout, "I love
incest," while holding it.
Now for the incestuous one,
I'm gonna have to finish that here
because I didn't have enough
time to actually grab it
and shout it because literally
the moment I picked it up--
- Sounds really convenient to me.
- The literally the moment I picked it up,
the staff came over and just took it out.
He was like, this one, okay.
Took it out of my hand.
I was like, oh.
- I can't even tell him I like incest.
How dare you.
- I was like, wait, no, I
have to say I like incest.
- It's just like stage hazards.
It's no one's fault,
but you should have done it.
- I'll be happy to take half
a point for this honestly,
Because I'd--
- I'd be lucky to get off of this show.
- I'd like to at least get half of one'
because I did buy...
I did finish half the challenge,
I did actually buy an incestuous figure.
I just literally didn't
have the time to get,
say the thing.
- If we're nice to you,
you're saying you'll be nice
to us at some point.
- I have been nice to you
guys, what do you mean?
- I go to his bag.
- Fine, you can have half the point.
It's the figure then.
- The figure--
- I'd shout it out on the
podcast so I can judge.
- What the fuck?
- Ladies and gentlemen that I shout out,
Air longa sensei just forgot.
(clapping)
Everybody, round of applause.
- Well, done and Joey Well done.
I'm proud of you. Proud of you, Joey.
- We go to prison.
- This is the only one.
I was like there has
to be an Orima figure.
Please let there be an Orima.
This the first time I ever in my life
prayed for an Orima
figure, couldn't find it.
So I was like, fuck,
what else is incest? What else is incest?
I know, I lost the incest man right here.
So I ran up to God. I said,
bro, if you scratch my back,
I'll scratch yours.
What's an incest show.
- And I just gave him some
philosophical bul shit
that's I made up on the spot.
- Even though I saw about
10 or Maga sensei figures
along the way.
- Why is it so many?
- I dunno.
- I dunno. I dunno, it's
popular enough I guess, but...
- I guess replaces lemon Sal with...
- But yeah, there you go,
I found myself a sucky read figure.
It's actually not too bad.
To be honest with you.
I'm not exactly a fan of air Monga sensei,
but this is actually a pretty solid.
- I think you'd have the FBI
knocking If you said you were.
- Well, I mean, God should
be used to that by now.
This one was $211.
- $211 for an (mumbles)
- I don't know where...
I didn't have like your Eagles..
Like incest Eagle vision.
So this was the only one I could find.
- For once, I'm okay
North seeing the figure.
This is like a child's play mat.
What the fuck is that.
- I'll bring it out, I'll bring it out.
Don't worry.
I think it's supposed to
symbolize soggy reas like bed.
- What happens in this anime,
why is it children's starve.
- Because she is a hentai artist.
- She's a yeah...
She's the and the Airman Sensei
And the brother I believe is
an Airman good author, right?
- He is an author.
- How do I remember more
of ever among, since.
- I dunno man.
- Brochures, punted, he got
like the cause bed, bro.
What is that? She's not a hentai.
- Basically this figure,
this series is like the series from hell.
- It is.
- This is the series from hell.
- No, what the fuck
What the fuck is that?
- All right and...
- What the fuck.
- The grand reveal.
- Child's play mat.
- I mean, how old is
Sonia again in the show?
- I have no idea.
- You do not want to know.
I probably normally--
Probably wouldn't illegal.
- Probably we're not going
to be allowed to say that.
- And I'm really not allowed to say it.
There's some kind of light
liability on (mumbles).
(laughing)
I think this goes, where does this go?
- Basically the series
should burn in hell.
And that's why I named it up so much.
- I remember certain
video, Giguk making a video
called I love this dumpster
truck or something like that.
- I think it's called Aramark
sensei is a masterpiece.
- It's a masterpiece.
(laughing)
There you go. There's the
masterpiece right there.
I love incest.
Hey guys I completed the challenge.
You proud of me.
- I'm proud. I'm proud of you.
- Proud of me.
- Take one of the figures away right now.
- If you've completed,
you've completed your character arc now.
- I did it guys.
He probably be mom.
(speaking off the microphone)
I'll keep this here because
I still have to set it up.
- But what were your guys challenge?
- I mean, I guess I'll take
out my first challenge.
- Why don't we tell us the
challenges first Garnt,
so you have some reason to understand.
- Well you know the first challenge.
Yeah, so obviously you guys
know my first challenge
because we told you to buy it
'cause you guys told me to buy it.
And I'm gonna be honest with you,
I'm not exactly unhappy with it. honestly,
because you guys are
gonna get maybe by again?
- Ram, Ram,
Ram, maybe by Ram or Mamaco
- Not Mamiko, there was
one other fucking bitch.
(laughing)
- Whoa, the shore girl
with big bird youngers.
- Azaki Chan.
- Azaki.
- And he would have actually hurt my soul.
I'm like $200 for an ezaki chan figure.
It was a bunny, he was...
- Mama go though. I can get behind this.
I can get behind this.
Oh, it's already open scar scar.
- It's from this series
called (in foreign language)
- I can read the last line of conduit.
- Yeah. So this is a...
The alternate title for
this is the MILFy Sekai
cause that what she is.
Mum with her to hit multi target attacks.
I think in English.
- That is one big figure.
That's a thick mama, right?
God damn Darn.
- Where are we going to put that?
That's actually really nice.
This is a really nice figure.
We can show bunny girl figures, right?
Yeah.
Yeah. Blessed plate sensei.
Oh, thank you.
Those are some high heels. Look at that.
How do I put this in?
Okay. There we go.
Honestly, honestly, I'm
happy with this vigor.
So I got this premise and it's
a goal she's going to huge
dog.
Huh? I would like to have one.
Well, well what do you think
when I, as the milk match,
better than wherever the this is,
I haven't even finished it.
This isn't even a masterpiece.
So, so Joey, so Joe,
this one is still got to pay
for it and take it off the
queen, the queen.
Okay. So Joey, when you are
asking for incest anime,
he could have also caught this one.
Oh yeah. Because yeah, because she does,
does she does do weird stuff
with a song. Yeah, she does.
She does watch. Yeah.
So she gets in like a slime
bottoms on the premise of the
show.
The premise of the show is a
son gets easy collide with his
mom. And this is the
same era Monga sensei.
Oh, they're not related by blood.
No. They're fully related
by blood came out of her.
Yeah. Like he came out, he, he
got birthed from her vagina.
He came out of the womb and everything.
She raised him and she,
she turned him into a degenerate
under, there are some very,
very, like, I'll drink to that.
There are some very sexy scenes.
He's talking about episode two.
I'm talking about episodes.
So in episode two,
I think let's just say that's
the episode that made me drop
the show in episode two,
I believe they fight a
slime monster. Right?
And the slime monster has acid or slime,
which corrodes everything
except the body, the body.
So it melts, it melts the
clothes off and guests,
guests who gets that
slime all over her body.
And guess who is on her body
when the slime goes on her
body? Yes, it is her son.
Yep.
And the sun is slime. Where does that go?
I don't actually remember
the scene. I don't,
I believe it just goes and
gets rid of her clothes.
He has like, foster plenty of slime.
I hope not.
But yeah,
that was the one episode
that made me drop the shot.
Otherwise amazing artwork. Yeah.
One of my favorite autos.
She has amazing artwork.
Yeah.
And they probably got
one efficient for that.
Yeah. I love, I have a.
Yeah. I think I told her,
I said I have a couple
of bunny goal figures.
Ah, baby.
I wonder, I really hope so.
Nope.
Oh too thick.
boy.
- All right. Well that's a.
- Figure. Yeah.
I thought you would like this one. I do.
- And that would have taught
me about that slides. But.
- Now that you've told me
about this line, clearly.
- Shard is already taken by something.
- So on. It was the first
figure that you bought.
- Then I spent a lot
of money here, so yeah.
- Do the challenges first. Perfect.
Bloody hell. That's a long receipt.
You bet it is.
- So I had one challenge which
was to buy something from a
movie that Jerry buy something
from the animated that Joey
has watched in 2021,
which is a little easier
than watched by when you.
- Yeah. Yeah.
It's not like I've seen zero
this year. Unbelievably.
I know.
- This wasn't too difficult as
last minute before we had to
leave the store,
I remembered that Joey in
length had spoken about watching
the even galleon movie.
So I bought, I just bought neighbor.
Oh, nice.
Nice. What you're going to say.
You're going to be like, oh,
it's not the right type from the right.
Because I know it has the movie on it.
- Yeah, it is.
It isn't it isn't though. No, it isn't.
It isn't.
That's not even close. You
had so many aver options.
No, actually that's you know what it is?
That's not even like cannon, even Gilliam.
What's even going, this is
evangelical on in train form.
It's even going what the?
Yeah. Yeah.
It's not even an Eva. It's an
Eva collab with seen cardio.
Which did you buy? You
had so many choice of Ava.
Eva. Shinkansen.
You done.
- Even galleon right
there. No, no, no, no.
Is it.
- Kelly on collab with.
- If it's a Joe, Joe collab
with a t-shirt it's still Joe,
Joe, you know what I mean?
It's still even galleon.
What are you on about?
- I cannot, I should get the point.
Yeah. That's ah, that's proper.
- They also bought an even
galleon gone. So you both.
- Lose a point.
- Yes we do. Yeah.
I got, I got, I got a
point and then lost it.
Yeah.
- No, you didn't even get a point.
You lost it.
You don't even you.
If we're not going to count
my recent enemy. Well,
we're not counting this waver.
- Bro.
- That's a shink stone. This
is that's a train train.
That's a literal literal transformer.
That's cute.
You literally could have
picked so many even galleon
figures. I can pick the one.
That's a train either.
- None of either.
I get no point and can't gets
a point or can't lose a point.
And I got no point.
- No, wait, wait what?
No, no, no, no, no.
You both lose a.
- Point.
- I lose one point and
you lose two points. Why.
- Do I lose two points? No, no, actually.
- No, no, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
you lose a point and God doesn't
or it's both of you lose a
point.
- No. So yeah.
And you don't get why I get the point.
I also then lose that
point and got loses one.
- Yeah.
He doesn't get a point and
he also loses the point.
- I'm happy. I'm content
with making gone loser point.
- I will give you the point.
If you can, if you can say that,
I get the point for the
Kevin's on the iPhone.
- It's the exact same day
he gave you the half a point for the.
- Cause the exact same
vein. No it's no, I'm sorry.
I don't remember watching
shin Cutty on in 2021.
- Boston about watching shin Kelly
on it's about getting one.
- From.
I need to remember that being
in four point. Oh, I'm sorry.
- Figure series. It literally
says it on the book.
- At least I to no corner. Why
did you choose that figure?
There was so many evil figures.
- There because all of them
look so boring. What about.
- The BNA? One that you
said you were going to buy?
- Yeah, I found out that
because we literally.
- Did a video this year on the Netflix.
- And then I went to my calendar
and we actually filmed that
in like December. Oh really?
Sorry.
So can't lose this one
point and I get nothing.
So I lost the point I gained.
- Now we both know you
both lose a point a point.
- Yeah. And then I get the point.
Forget you don't get the point.
I only lose the point if I get the point.
Cause you'd have to admit that
it's an Eva for me to lose
the point to begin with.
So what I'm saying is if you would.
- That means it's either
you'd lose no points or you lose two
points. No.
- It's either I lose no
points or can't gets a point.
- No, I don't get any point.
It doesn't get any points. I just don't.
- Lose a point.
Then I get a point
losing the point. If you,
if you admit that you lose a point,
you're admitting this isn't even gallium.
- This isn't, this isn't okay.
You know what? You know what?
I'd rather, I'd rather not
admit that that's Neven galleon.
Then admit that we got
the same figure. So well,
I'll tell you what. Yeah.
So Gordon doesn't lose any
points and you don't lose any
points. How's that?
- We're exactly where we started. So.
- So both of you have zero.
- This isn't even gallium.
It literally says it on the.
- Box. I did not watch Evangelian
with a Shinkansen reboot.
I did.
- I don't know what you, Jerry,
I watched the English dub
where they had this in it. I.
- Look, look over there.
- We lead the way.
- Do you remember that
scene in full point? Oh,
when they bust out the evening
mean, you can't say, look,
we literally in Ava three when
I plus one got introduced to
Avon, Galyon, infinity,
but even in the infinite possibilities,
I don't think that was one of.
- Them. This is one of the
infinite possibilities.
- I don't think even infinity
can take account of whatever the
that is. I don't think so.
- Is that why you acting
so smug smuggling?
- No, I'm acting so smart
because I know that's not evangelic.
That clearly says shin Cardi
on, on the side of the bag.
I can read it's even.
- Galleon. What the is.
- This? That's the T field.
- From even galleon, right?
No, I'll bring it.
- Bringing the attention away
from this pound for a moment.
This is habitually. Oh my God.
- Holy.
Why are you buying figures?
They don't fit in the shelf.
That's so none of these
figures fit in the shelf. God.
- I went with my heart. Okay.
I grew up with my heart. This
just looks like a cool figure.
Look at this. Why are.
- We going to put this back in the.
- Toilet? Right?
There's just going to be a,
there's just going to be a
toilet shrine with all the.
- I'm trying to be the and actually
think about all set for a
moment.
- Yeah. See this one fits
perfectly on the set.
That's not going.
- On the Fits perfectly on the monetize.
Every episode.
- Yeah. In the meantime, let me show you.
Oh wait. Oh, you got.
- Well, my name, you got an eight for me.
- I don't give a about you guys.
When you buy an apex
legend one. This is my.
- Main cause is that to.
- Do a challenge? No.
- He just wanted it. I
just want a Pathfinder.
He's my main.
- I got, I got the perfect one.
If we're, if we're talking meme games.
Okay. I got the perfect one right here.
Right? And what are your eyes?
- I saw some little girls.
Why don't you buy this? I got the.
- I got the full box set.
sake.
I couldn't not buy this.
This is absolutely amazing.
No.
- You did.
- Gone.
Wait, did you buy the same thing?
- Oh no.
Alright.
- Joey, Joey, what did you buy?
Exactly. I bought wait.
- Oh.
- Oh,
the buildable action figure
among us five to collect five.
Alright. So one of my,
one of my challenges was of
course to get a plushy and I had
plenty options to find, I
love character plus shoes.
I then hidden right in the corner,
Joey and right in the corner was the.
- Yeah. You might lose a point.
Yay.
- You know what worth it
for the humongous, you know?
You know what though? You know though,
I didn't want to stop there.
Cause the plushy, Mora, Magus,
the plush. He needed a friend.
Okay. The mushy.
Okay. Look,
I know the challenge was just
to buy one character plushy,
but I felt like, you know, you can't,
you can't play among us with
just one, just one person.
Okay? Okay.
The character needs a friend.
Steve let's go boys.
Steve. We're signing our
own smash bros right here.
All right. Well I'm listen.
Smash when I couldn't knock.
It was too perfect. What is this?
So these are like buildable, I guess like,
like lucky bought boxes for.
Can we get the boxes
off the table? Luckily,
none of these are the
red as we read them all.
So does it count? Is
it the same character?
I don't know. Does it count?
Cause none of them are really.
- Well.
Let's open them up and find out
who is from the same series.
None of these are red though.
He's from the same.
- Series, but you've bought
how many series from Joe Jones.
- Only one set of duplicates.
- Yeah. But that was only one set.
Right? Because he was deal.
So, so you, so if I'm county, this is one.
- Yeah. Yeah.
So you guys, you got the among the sky.
That's literally a character.
- I got, I got the red among us.
They're not different than Fred.
There's a light on this. The
purple, the green, the black,
the white and the Gregg.
- They'll all the same
catalog. Look ledgers,
different costumes.
- Hello. W when you're voting
for someone to get off, right?
Do it's the same. It's
a different costume.
It's the same character.
- Yeah. We've already established.
We both lose a point and I
get a point. Cause it's Ava.
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
We've established that. We
both don't lose a point.
- Yeah.
- No, he has not bought
a red among us carrots.
So you can see box.
- They are the same.
- Character.
You vote someone after you
go through your mother's
character, you say red is SaaS corner.
You don't go.
- What's the name? It's red.
It's.
- Red. He's a crook.
It's a red crewmate it's a fresh.
- Yeah. And that's a, crewmate Fred.
It's a red crew mate. But at
the same time as a green car,
that Logi Joey's probably bought
like 15 duplicates because.
- I'm county. This is one.
Cause it came in one box.
- Well, if you open them all up,
how many characters are there?
Five you have, I'm sorry.
You have five duplicates
because this is one. All right.
Well you can either take the
five minus points or you can
take the one minus points here that.
- It does not work like that. It does.
No, no, no.
- No, no, no, no, no.
And you're even trying to argue.
- I am going to argue
this till the day I die.
There was a red among us character.
I will happily take the L I agree.
If there was a red Amanda's
character, I'd be like, Joey,
we got the same guy.
Cause.
- I literally.
- I literally tried,
like I literally like
predicted maybe one of these
characters,
maybe one of these guys wore
by and among us character.
Right. So I was like, so I was like, ah,
which I actually had to pick
one that I thought the guys
wouldn't actually buy. So I picked red.
- I think there's no real.
It sucks that you both got the crew mates.
So it doesn't matter. Now you
both have support in the end.
- There isn't.
- A point off of them birth.
- What do you think your most?
- Definitely.
- This under the contention.
- Contention. Ashley.
Isn't this the stupidest honor.
- Your honor. I object.
- You can't. You will look
like clouds on the video.
- Emergency meeting.
Just see meeting.
I would like to talk.
- You really can't believe
this is what you're trying to argue for.
You both lose one point. Oh my God.
There's no doubt.
- I actually bought a B stars figure
because I wanted to take
it away from corner just in
case it as well. Hell yeah, no,
no, no.
Not now. Like in my, in my personal life,
don't tell me that.
You're like, oh, that's
the one I've always walked.
I pre-ordered this before he came out.
Cause I was looking around
and I'm just like, well,
I've got all my points. Let's try it.
Let's try to.
So you know it anyway. It
didn't matter in the house.
It's such a nice figure as well. It is.
Did you even watch the
stars this year though? Yes.
Season two. I did.
Okay. So.
- You take one point off of them. Ashley.
- Is on the contention.
We, we we're,
we're having points on the
contention this year, the.
- Take it off with them.
- It's under contention.
- This is not under, under what?
The court of the clowns.
What the you want to do?
The court.
- Of the law,
the court court of among
the quarter of the sauce.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
But if we're going far by among us laws,
then the majority wins, right?
It's by majority, majority vote.
So therefore therefore you would have.
- If you're posting agreement,
you can't just both keep
making up rules and then say we
have the majority it's literally.
- We did an emergency meeting.
We voted and we voted
that your opinion was.
- Because you're in the same game,
the same figure and the same
characters. So they both.
- Colorblind.
- The same character.
- There is not none of these
look like this character.
- They literally look the exact same.
They're literally the
same character. I call it.
- The same.
How can like six of.
- Them go around at the
same time costumes gone?
Because why? Because they're
all the same character.
- The different characters, Jonah.
- Oh, yes.
They'll live. That is looks pretty.
The point of the thing is that
you can change color because
there is no distinction between
them because they are the
same character.
- And what if,
what if this guy's name is Gary
and this guy's name is Greg.
It's not, oh, how do we know?
Have you, have you looked into.
- Among us at all?
Any names? They're all the same character.
- So every fat, so all
among us characters,
I just clones of each other.
I like to hear opinions among his fans.
Anyone who's knows anything
about among us little,
I think can back us up that a,
these are all different characters.
- We literally.
- Can. We bring up the.
- Developers?
We're going to find out who's.
- One. All right.
Bring out the what else is in my box?
What else am I going? I'm
just going to keep rolling.
Yeah. So the other challenge I
had was to buy a wall scroll.
So I just bought a even
need to see it. No.
Okay. No one cares.
No one has, ah, I mean like
my challenges were too.
I mean, one of them was this
and one of them was that.
So that's both of my challenges.
Cause the next challenge was to a squat.
Anytime I saw zero figure and
I really regret not going to
the gym because my God
that burnt the next day.
I'm not even joking. Right.
Cause now that I've moved
into a house with stairs,
just going up to my bedroom
hurts. So I'm just like, I just,
after that, I just bought
figures that I liked, oh,
I want it to get that as county figure.
I want it to get that so bad
just because I never seen her
fully, fully, fully, fully represent.
Boy, I have a red candy at home, actually.
Hell yeah. I mean is still
making fully Coley figures.
Is this new?
I think this is from the
second hand on the second one.
The second answer, right?
Yes. Literally says 1990.
No, no.
That's when it came out. Oh yeah.
So that's that nice.
Ashley, can you get me the lamp?
- That was just something that I was.
- Going to buy. So I kind of
saw me reaching out for this.
I thought it was too cool. Not to get,
I want it to get this full
myself for the longest time,
but I got a majority. It's not a failure,
but I thought it looked
cool in the studio.
It's a Majora's mosque
painted light up statue. Yeah.
Sydney actually went back to
army army and bought this like
two days after. It's pretty sick.
It is not really good. That
looks, that would look amazing.
Oh yeah. Good idea.
So.
- A bunch of from anime movies
just to win this prize. Oh.
- Ton of stuff.
- 5,000 Of them that I get that dog.
- Oh wow.
It's old Jubilee too. Yeah.
I don't know why. I
didn't think of Jubilee.
I remember the challenge
of animate only movies.
And I was like, oh man,
how many hosts soda on it?
No, because I was just like Cinco figures.
I was like, pre-med, that's
a that's anatomy only Kira.
Jerry's.
- Going to buy it.
Cause it was the most animated figures.
- Yeah. I thought I got mistaken.
I thought it was the most expensive.
- So I bought six from.
- Ghibli.
If you go, you've got
that point at that point.
But do you have a majority of
Moss lamp? I don't think so,
but I have a.
- I believe this is sick though.
Like you can actually put food
in it and it will like chomp
it and spit it out.
- What do you need that for? I don't.
- Know. I just thought
it was, it was cool.
I have no face figure that
can chomp and spit you out.
Fair enough.
- Yeah. I guess my car fire from hell.
That's cute. Calcify Monday.
My next pickup.
Yeah.
Yeah. You can see, you can hear,
you can hear it nappy cheering
because is it all killer?
It's the only thing that gets
Navy excited. It's all stuff.
Okay. It's okay to alter.
- The. Is this, what is this?
- Okay, so we have the best looking fate.
You wrote for a character and you are,
unfortunately it was
from fate To alter those,
the best character from
falling asleep. This,
this is like in terms of
like her ranking in terms of
gameplay, it's like, it's not the best,
but in terms of design, holy.
This is one of my favorite
designs. And I agree.
And if you bought this, you
would've got a point, Joey,
because I don't own her. I
tried, tried rolling for her.
Did not get her.
Well, that's what we'll find
out about that lady that was in
Monterey. I was in Mandara.
Yeah. And that's, and that's
why, you know, if you can't,
if sometimes you roll for a
Gacha and you don't get it,
so sometimes you go out
your way and you own them
physically. And that's, that's what I did.
Okay. Okay.
So my biggest challenge at army
army was to get a figure of
a character that is American.
Okay. Now I had to
double check here, right?
It didn't say anime character.
It just said character.
Right? Because admittedly,
there isn't a whole lot of
American anime characters, right?
A few that guy from
Yu-Gi-Oh there's a few,
but definitely not famous
enough to make a figure out of.
Right. But luckily I checked
with the staff and I said,
okay, it doesn't necessarily
have to be enemy.
It doesn't say needs to be animated.
So as long as it's an American
and you guys have no problems
with it being an American,
then I thought it was okay.
Right.
So I got probably one of the
most American people ever.
LeBron James.
- LeBron, James.
- American, you can't argue.
It's a figure.
I'll give you that. I'll give you that.
I'll give you that two represents.
We have a LeBron James speaker
in the studio applause later.
Well, if LeBron James can
appear in space, sham,
he can appear on trash tastes. Okay.
Clean anime character. He was in space.
But I thought, I, cause like I.
- Said, like movable.
- You can make him dunk.
You can make him do the finger
thing as well. It's great.
I love this.
It's pretty cool. I'm going
to take him out actually.
Yeah.
Do you have any more figures? Kona?
Oh.
- Yeah. A few.
- Four, four walls.
Do you want to? I think
I only have one more.
Right? I think I only have one more.
I don't have a few more,
but do you want to take some more out?
Really?
Thanks. Awesome.
Awesome. You know what?
You know what guys? I was
this close to buying one.
Well, I was this close.
- No, at least the reason I
asked what your price was.
It sounds like, at least
let me be mine cheaper.
And it was cheaper. So
you overpaid by 20 bucks.
- That's all right. I'm
going to take one of these.
All right. Two points off, I guess.
Cause we're already at 2.2
points off. You want to.
- See it?
- Good man. I'm good guys.
We can have one in both show.
We'll have one in each corner.
- So one of my challenges
is to buy a male character.
And this was it. Why?
- That one? You couldn't
go for any other male.
- Character.
There's a reason why I chose
because I also bought something
else to go along with it.
- Okay.
Oh, you bought the motor bike.
Oh, you bought the motorbike.
I'm so glad you bought that
because I saw it and I was like,
I don't know because it's not
going to give me any points or
anything, but oh, there's altar.
Oh, look at that.
Okta, Alta dude.
God down. Oh, it is easily the
best looking fake character.
I'm sad now that I don't
own her, this, this is,
this is making me sad. I
now know that you don't own.
- So this is the bike
and yeah, it's a big box.
I bought this because I,
while I was going to buy this,
cause it was $600.
And I thought at the
time I'm I'm, I'm like,
I was very confident the time
that it was the most expensive
figure. I don't know if you
guys bought another one.
I still, you know, from
all the stores so far,
I think it is. I think so far.
Yeah.
So the reason why I bought the
other figure was to try and
secure the challenge of
spending the most on one series.
- Yeah. How much, how much was this bike?
$600.
Oh my God. It's like a whole mix.
It's like a foreign operation. Oh my God.
Look at that. This is not
a podcast episode anymore.
This is just an unboxing episode.
Like how we've just made a
glorified on boxing episode.
I know audio liens are going
to be so confused if you're,
if you've come this far. Oh,
oh so cool.
Yo, I can only get so rank dark.
Holy. That's amazing.
Oh, it moves.
Holy.
That is so cool.
I hope you can yeah.
I'm sorry, Canada.
I hope, I hope you can put Canada on that.
God. That looks good.
That is so cool.
Again. That's not that,
that supersedes a figure.
I think that's, that's just a statue.
I really hope you can
get him to sit on it.
- So the main reason I wanted to get
it was because I was near
certain that yeah, it did indeed or.
- War.
I mean, that's impressive.
But look at my boy, little more clean.
Look at that physique.
That perfect physique.
Look at that. Look at that.
That's so cool.
- So I wonder why it doesn't
really stand up very well. I.
- Think even in the movie it
kind of leans when it stands.
Yeah.
I think, I think it needs
to stand on the side.
The boys.
- Yeah. And the set though,
I thought that would look sick
behind us having, you know,
a one to six scale of the bike.
I just thought you can't say no to that.
- You know what battle is?
Just merely it looks amazing.
Worth wasting two points
for so yeah. I agree.
You know what? I ain't even mad.
I lost two points. Cause we got that.
We got that in the set.
- Right, right.
Isn't this sick. Right.
- All right. You move away for LeBron.
James say he's like, hi it me, LeBron.
I got home. I got it.
I got on my show. Contently
figure because of course I did.
I didn't know if they
started making them already,
but apparently they did. Oh nice.
I would have preferred Roxy. A gray rat.
Yes. Her name is gray rat.
Like.
- Some light iron mouse copyrights.
- Honestly you look at
that. Look at the design.
I can't believe I am mouse copied from,
I can't believe we showed you
10 say ripped off iron man.
I can't believe you mouse.
Yeah. This is the last
member of V show Joe.
Apparently it is gray, right?
Yeah.
I mean, I mean, I think,
I think we show good tenancy
is far and beyond the best
Easter I've ever seen.
So I just, I just wanted, I
just wanted some presentation.
Yeah. Some representative
for the ISA guys.
I started watching.
Has it actually. Yeah.
Yeah. This looks so good.
I finished season one the
other day when I talked about
this. It's awesome.
I love it. It's such a good.
- Show. Sorry boys.
I was pretty distracted, but it move.
- That's so cool. Yeah.
That's the noise and mace.
Well, he needs the gun with that.
Yeah, he does.
There's a gun.
- And he's the big off gun
without we don't need the gun right
now. It's fine.
Yeah. Yeah.
Common leave. We bought
the exact same figure.
We post last two points.
- I I'm not, I, you know what?
The bike, I'm not even mad.
I'm not even mad. Cause he got the bike.
- I committed. I committed.
- Jerry that's all right. I'm
taking, they got the Tinder,
right? Pout down.
Look at that. Look at that.
It's it's it's the small details, man.
It's the small details. It's
all about the simple thing.
- All right. Sharp.
Your, figure it out.
Huh? Show it off.
I'm stop taking nine years
to inbox it. I'm sorry.
- Corner. I'm sorry.
- Rip it. Open.
Rip and tear.
- I thought you didn't.
- Do that with your
figures. He's got Google.
He's got Google maps on
the bike. Yo let's go.
- Google maps, bro.
What the?
Yo, that we're thinking ahead.
- Do the detail is insane. Yeah know.
- It is like model car level.
- But the light turns as well.
- That's so cool.
Does the light turn on?
- I dunno. I don't think so.
Nice.
- That's not bad. Yeah.
Very clean. Oh.
We have to actually build it. Okay.
We probably can't do it now. We got that.
- Yeah. It's cut.
The mind comes on. I'll
just show the camera.
Show. The camera just comes
with a bunch of different
customizations to the back so we can.
- Build that on streaming.
- Yeah. Okay.
Do you want to take this away?
I'll just leave this on here.
- I still have one more figure by the way.
And it's the biggest one I have.
- I said that one. That one.
- Right there. Do you want
to, we don't have to unbox it.
I've done boxes. Just put
the box on the thing, Joe.
I didn't know you are a
Hudson name. Yuku fan.
What can I say? I like anime.
We've gotten to the point
where the figures we've bought.
We buy are so big that it's
actually blocking us. Yeah.
So I'm not going to unbox this,
but this is the Memorial dress,
Hudson and MICU motion for wall.
For the anniversary.
- Was it a memorial?
- [Malin] For every Nico Nico Chokaigi.
- For every Nico Nico
Chokaigi there's a...
Nico comes with a new dress.
- There's the box.
- That one is also the one
that is closest to 420 for me.
- Okay, we'll--
- Funny enough, one of
the things I have left
is the closest to for 420 for me.
- [Joey] Nice.
- [Garnt] Okay. All right.
- I don't know what the fuck this is.
It to happened to be so close to 420.
- [Joey] What the fuck is that?
- We've got two bikes.
(laughs)
- No fuck off.
- We can put the other
one, kind of on this one.
(laughs)
Thank God.
- I do not know what this is.
- This is mega zone in two, three.
- I don't know what that is.
- I'm guessing it's like a super obscure.
- It's probably a super old meka.
Will I get destroyed for
calling this a transformer?
'Cause it kind of looks
like a transformer.
- So I'm guessing this
is some very OG show.
- It's a Garlin like a different character
from a different show.
- It's fancy right?
- I'm guessing it's rare or something
'cause it's $420.
- I think just looking at
the font of the show name,
It looks like an old show.
- Where did you find this?
- In like the Mac section of ArmiArmi.
- Oh, okay.
- But like that's what it looks like.
- So I guess, yeah.
I don't wanna be here all
day opening for you guys.
So yeah, we'll just take
that off stream now.
That's my closest. I have one more.
How many do you have left?
- I'm done.
- Do you wanna go first?
(mumbles)
- Okay. So, oh you go first
'cause this one's a hentai figure.
- My last challenge was
something from anime
that the boys haven't watched.
And what better than an
anime that isn't even out yet
'cause there's no possible way
you could have watched it.
- [Both] Oh.
- Nice.
- I was running around the store
and I thought there's a few option.
- How can (mumbles)
- It's been announced.
- Announced.
- Yeah.
- And you haven't watched it.
- We haven't watched it. No one's seen it.
- Nobody's seen it except
for the people working on it.
So I thought perfect,
and you know me and Jerry like Akina.
(murmurs)
I don't play it anymore.
- You didn't get the chin one though.
- See, I went for the more expensive one,
but this one was,
I know you liked it.
- I liked Shane more than Army.
- Well, why is the four-star?
- No, she is.
- She's literally the first unit you get.
She's just kind of repeat though.
- She's literally the default unit,
doesn't even know how to open.
- Her final is E2 is like OPS shit.
I'm sorry if you don't play Arknigts.
- Yeah, well, so this is the
main character from Arknights.
I'm guessing she'll be
in the anime as well.
- I think she'll be the
main goal in the anime.
That's so nice though. 'Cause I have...
I seen the Ninroids of Armia.
- I don't like the Androids,
but I really liked the Ninroid for Amia
but like a full figure into that.
I actually might go and buy this.
It's actually so nice.
If there's one thing Arknights
does absolutely amazingly,
it's character design.
I think there is no better game
that I can do better character design.
And the day is so cool.
Like I've been looking,
I've been eyeing up some Arknight figures
that haven't been released yet.
Like the Freight one that's coming out,
It looks amazing as well.
It's coming out next year.
- I remember it being super P.
She's still over here.
- [Joey] She's still OP.
- That's that's the Auckland.
- Actually, so cool. I love that.
- Omira so cute, dude.
- Yeah. Well that's that was 150 bucks.
Nice. Ah, I thought,
it's completely a challenge
and it's a pretty good figure.
- But what was your challenge to get?
Oh yeah, we haven't seen.
- We haven't seen, I.
- Haven't yet scenes in the game.
the PV counter to the
advertisements count.
- That's all right.
I've watched dune. I saw
the trailer a good movie.
- I see the advertisements
on the train all the time.
- Yeah, there you go.
I thought was a cool thing.
- No complaints. That's a
nice We're at a point for me.
Yeah. So I've got one more figure.
And of course, I mean,
I mean he has like a really
good selection of hinted lewd
figures, right?
Yes. So I wanted to get a hentai figure.
I figure, I found the weirdest
hentai figure I've ever seen. Okay.
Bet. Okay.
So, so on the front it looks
like a normal hint I figure.
Right. But the figure is just a nice.
- I'm gonna have to blow that.
- It's literally just, this is like the,
this is like the way they
get sucked into a wall in the
wall. You only get half the figures.
It's just the ass whole.
- How are we going to display?
- Oh my.
- It's amazing. But we could show it God.
How much?
- Oh God. It comes with, it comes with,
it comes with an art book.
- The, the history of Ooh.
All right.
- Luckily I have these emojis.
Things are covering me,
but Alexa know it's it's
actually quite wholesome.
Yeah. See this.
Maybe not. I'm going to,
I'm going to have to,
I'm going to have to.
- All of that box for that.
Wait.
- For that.
Okay. This article is
actually quite wholesome.
It's like some, there's like
some nice artwork in here.
What's the point of the whole book.
I think it's the artwork
done by the same guy.
Maybe who designed this figure
or design this character that
the figure is based off of. I
mean the cover is like, wow.
- Yeah, we can't show that.
- The back of the book. I
guess I was fine, but yeah,
the front is wow.
- Okay. Ganz.
Ava. Whoa.
How much was that? Ava again gone.
- Oh, it's getting gasoline in.
Totally shill. Look at that.
Ava. It's getting.
- Filled up here. I've
got room on my place.
- I can't, I don't know
which one do you ever is?
I bought is so cool. Or maybe
don't hold it like that.
Yeah.
- That's the.
- It's getting filled up.
Yeah. Oh.
- Bro. That's pretty sad.
- That's actually so sick. All right.
Enough about the Ava.
Say you say.
- That actually.
I love this. Why?
Why would you want that?
Just, you know.
- It's just dumb. Wait, is
there like a wall attachment?
You can tell. I think he can
put it on like your phone.
- Okay. Now that's
Before, before I decide how good it is.
- This was, I believe $130.
I would, I would, I would,
I happily would buy that.
- If it was over 150, I'd have been like.
- That is one of the best things
I've ever seen in my life.
- All right.
How much did you spend in Miami total?
- I spent an army army $1,017 gone. How.
- Much did you spend?
- $10201.
- I spend a total of $1,580. Holy crap.
At Amie Amie. Jesus.
- Holy. Well, mostly it was on that right.
- There was like $800 on a.
- So yeah. And you lost two points for it.
- But it was worth it.
Cause I was thinking the bike
is probably going to be the
most visibly, like striking
on the other thing,
because none of this can
fit on the desk or there
You can fit this thing
called we can't show that.
- It's so funny. This catalog.
- All right, well that's Amie Amie.
Let's go to the next store.
- All right.
But last and certainly not
least is the final store
monarchy. It was brand new.
I think we tried to go
to monarchy last year.
We just didn't have enough time to again,
this year we finally got it.
It is an absolute smorgasbord
of just random August
smorgasbord of random in there. Yeah.
I'm really excited to go to
monarchy. Cause like we always,
when we go to Akihabara or
anywhere a monarchy is we always
gotta hit up that store because
it's literally a lottery.
Cause you never know what you can find.
You can find some of the coolest
and then sometimes you go
on the you go there and you
find some of the dumbest. Right?
So it was like, how did you
guys feel going into Monda?
Rocky? Do you feel like
you had enough budget?
I had more than enough budget.
In fact I had to make sure I
got as close to 3, 3, 3, 3 as
possible in monarchy,
which is like impossible.
Yeah.
- I have like 500 bucks left. Yeah.
Oh really? Yeah.
I had like nothing left.
I had like 500 bucks just
to meet the criteria.
You did spend a ton. It,
I had to go to actually take stuff out.
I was able to spend $500 at Andrae. Oh.
Okay. I still want to get
quite a lot of things.
Yeah.
- Let's go. What was it?
So we had one challenge for Mondo.
- Mine was to buy a
figure from a show that.
- Mine was to buy a fate figure
that God hasn't pulled for or
doesn't have in FGM.
Joe's got mine was to
ask the store clerk for a
recommendation.
Yeah. I'm just gonna
lose a point right away.
- How many.
- Do you have? I'm not going to lie.
I totally forgot that we were
doing duplicate characters.
I thought it was only duplicate figures.
- No, no, no.
That's extra extra.
We've learned the hard way
about duplicate characters out.
How many points have you.
- Lost?
I lost two points now to do that.
- Because he has full deals.
Now he bought three yet at a stop.
Does the Don this is Don
Jonathan one count. Yeah.
- I mean it's it's it's like a duo.
- No, no, no, no, no.
Dio is there.
XEO is clearly there.
It's not like the spirit of.
- That's the total of two points.
Cause my Dio buying obsession
because you'll love the deal.
Well,
the reason I actually bought
this one was because I wanted
to get as close as possible to the number.
And this was one of them
that I chose. Again.
I totally forgot about the, the duplicate,
the duplicate thing.
I ended up buying this, but I mean,
there's a lot to keep track
of, but I also got very,
very close to the 3,333.
- Nice. All right.
So my one was that I had to
buy a FGO character that God
doesn't have on FGO.
Now I'm not gonna lie.
It's been way too long
since I played or myself.
So tell me your thought thought
process and this cause like
the whole process was okay.
I knew all of the basic
characters that you get at FGR but
the ones that are just like can't rotate.
So those were obviously out
of the window, I thought,
all right. I talked about
it with NABI, my camera man.
Who's like an FGO expert and
we basically made it. Yeah, we,
we, we basically like did a
hypothesis on what might he not
have?
I feel like you were really
lucky getting NABI as a camera
man. Cause if Connor got
here, yeah, he would've been,
he would've just had to
pick the fake character.
So I had the choice because
I wanted to get as close to
3, 3, 3, 3 as possible.
I had the choice to either
buy a shitload off Phaeton
Androids and just hope.
Just hope that you don't
have one of them. Right.
Or I just go big and go hard
on one figure to get as close
as possible. I hope you
went big and went hard.
And I went big and went
home. What did you get?
I have, I have a backup.
So I bought two fate ones. Okay.
So the first one I bought
because I'm not too confident.
Right? Do you have Easter?
I got spicy.
do you have Archer?
So you have the character age tall.
I'd say you have a Ishtar.
It's different though.
It's very different. It's very
different, but that's okay.
That's okay. You can think about
that because I have enough.
Okay.
Do you have gray?
No.
Go hell. Yeah.
Okay. Because this was
the big gamble for me.
Cause I was like, I, I
found great in the corner,
like the back corner. Right?
What is he? What is he?
The gray is like the, like a green repo.
Clashes it, zip Zipline with him.
I think it's the same.
I think it's the same now.
Yeah. I did not.
No way. Wait it's grave
released on us Faygo service.
I, yeah, the event came out recently.
Oh, okay.
So I mean, I wouldn't
have pulled for granny.
So I saw this and I looked
at NABI and I was like,
this is a recent characters.
And he was like, yes.
And I'm like, he hasn't been
playing that heavily recently.
So there might be a chance.
But I was so scared because
this cost $160. Right.
So I was like, I have
to go like all balls,
move rain on this. Can we
get this out of the box?
Can let's get this out of the box?
Cause this is actually
a really nice feature.
Oh, assassin.
Okay. But that's my great,
great is not even from
the mainline fate. Syria,
who is from the man? No,
I don't want to know that.
the point, the point at
a point onto me, baby.
All right. Add a pole out a 0.1 for Joey.
He deserves. Although,
although he had like the
biggest cheat sheet all time,
we might imagine having NABI
as a sheet sheet for that,
for that challenge, what
would you have done?
If you've got that challenge going on?
- I bought a saber figure or something.
Do your own Sabre.
- I actually, don't not
the main light safe.
I really, yeah.
Wow.
- Yeah. The only good character
for fate is Alexander.
The great Alexander,
the character, some fat.
- I really like his style.
So that's why also I was like
a Rin face or I'm just like,
anytime there's a red face
for sale. I know you like it.
That's okay. That's okay.
You know, you don't need to get, I.
- Want, I don't want us to get into fate.
Please.
- Buy another Dio figure. Go ahead.
Go ahead. Go.
- Ahead, Georgia figures.
Okay. Not Dios though.
I can't show us one of yours.
- So first thing I bought
was a Nico Robyn one. This was the,
this was the recommended
one from the store clerk.
Oh really?
- Because you could
have recommended a little more expensive.
- I did tell him, I did
tell them, you know,
price prices is an issue.
And he was just like,
so you asked the store
clerk for a recommendation.
What does he recommend? He
goes, do you like one piece?
And I'm just like, okay, you're doing,
you're doing your job.
- Like water.
- I'm like, I guess you're
just doing your job.
You literally picked the least
like inoffensive franchise.
You could go for like, you
know, post time, skip Robin.
Right. At least it's skip Robin.
But like, you know, you know about that.
- Right?
- You know that this.
- Is post I'm going to read it.
- The funny thing is,
so this was like one of the
first figures I got at the
store.
So obviously with, with
a random guy asking him,
asking him for a recommendation, you know,
I get it as a store
clerk. You don't wanna,
you don't want to go crazy.
You don't want to seem
too weird. You know?
You don't want to seem too.
- I used to wait for a wine
recommendation. He, you know,
you don't, if he offers
you the most expensive.
- He's not going to go for like.
- The fancy. He's going to
go for like a medium one.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
So afterwards at the end,
when I had to like buy another figure,
his station was actually next to the hint.
I figure section of course.
And I'm sure Sydney was
frothing at the mouth.
And when he saw us, when he
saw that, when he saw that,
hence I figures we're an option.
And that Sydney was like
choosing, hence I figure,
he was just like, oh, those were options.
I could have picked one of those.
Oh, why didn't you tell me?
Cindy went from literally the.
- If you ask a staff
recommendation, he's like, yeah.
The one with absolutely
gargantuan and a vagina.
You're going to be like, ah, what?
- Cause,
cause I will say out of all
the one piece figures he did,
like he did like pick the
most cultured one he possibly
could. That is true.
Robin is probably the most voluptuous.
- Yeah. It's just a normal
looking one piece for you.
Yeah. It doesn't look
like anything exceptional.
- I mean,
compared to like getting like
one of the male characters,
you know,
if it was like a standard Zuora
with like songy character,
then it would have been.
- Lately. I like McDonald's toy.
- Did I go to McDonald's every
day we got these for happy
meal. I'll be, I'll be like, mom,
we're getting McDonald's once again.
Right here. Okay.
That's a big site. Look at that.
I've already seen green, like
Lord Elma, Louise case falls,
which I believe is the spinoff. Oh,
that sounds pretty sweet. Yeah.
- It's very cool. Visually appealing.
- I'm pretty happy with it.
It's God doesn't have it.
So it's another saber face.
It's another yet another
savory face. Get this plastic.
You just have to rip the plastic. I mean.
- Well,
I will say I am glad that you
didn't buy a saber figure.
Yeah, because I bought a save it.
- Really wait corner.
You bought a fate figure.
Wait, hold on a second.
The phone does that mean?
You guys lose a point
because he has the hold up.
Hold up a second.
We can't show.
Oh actually you okay. Actually.
Okay.
So I didn't know this,
but apparently he'd
definitely did pick a culture.
De what the she was G string.
Oh, now we all know who my
favorite one-piece character is.
Okay. All right, Robin.
I see you. I don't
remember that in the anime.
Okay. Hold on a second question
time you bought a saber.
You have the big saving.
You bought a Russian bond.
Does that count?
Nah, I don't know.
What what'd you think? Kona.
- You bought a saber of the
or something. I don't know.
- It's literally the exact same.
They broke off.
- Oh.
I'm just gonna break it
off. Where did this come.
- From? Kind of what have you done?
What have you done to your fate figure?
- Oh, I already actually just broke.
Oh.
- My God. I think you lose
a point just for that to be,
I mean, it doesn't matter
because you both bought sabers.
So you lose a point.
So I take a point.
- Off.
Why don't you do.
- You didn't think he
was going to buy a Sable?
You didn't think you didn't
think I was going to buy a fate?
That's what, that's why I was.
That's why? When I got the,
like by a fate character,
that God doesn't have,
I was sweating my off.
Cause I'm like, I'm definitely
going to lose a point.
Cause he's probably bought
all the fake characters.
- Okay. Wait, do I put this?
How do I Mount this?
Just on that right.
- Now.
- If you want to figure this
out for me, that'd be great.
Please give me the style.
So actually, you know,
I have watched fate as much
as they meme that. I hate it.
I just hate it. Cause gone talks about it.
So much.
- Like a stand.
- Like a long thing.
Maybe it's in the bulk.
So something I don't know. Well.
- That's, that's a good saver thing.
- Yeah.
This broke off one of the things
I don't know why it's very
flexible.
- Oh it's oh, it's the little end here.
Yeah. I mean, I mean, if
you weren't careful with it,
which you definitely
want to careful with it.
- That's another point. Oh my God.
I'm losing so many points.
- Kind of like Connor's gaining
points and then just losing
them just as quickly.
Did you take a point off Garland corner?
Yeah. Okay.
All right. So.
- That's actually a good fate for you.
- But that's a really nice,
that is a very nice savored figure.
Got I'll give, I'll give
you that one corner.
I'll give you. There's only Nothing,
but fade here looking at its
current streamlined radius.
I know. Right?
He's taught. Great.
And save us.
Wait, I woke up on a podcast
where people bought fate,
fate figures and none of them
were bought by me. What the?
- How much do you think this cost?
This one? Yeah, 200.
- There's thing. That's about 200 right?
- 100 bucks.
- Oh wow. Wow.
Good. For 100 bucks.
Not bad at all.
- So yeah, like I said,
I mean on the whole fight
but I like phase zero a lot.
- That's a 40.
- I like unlimited blade
works and I like Phase Zero
- She watched heaven's field as well.
(laughs)
You here, you've learned boom.
You know me?
- You've literally ruined fate for me.
I actually can't watch it.
- What else did you guys buy? Oh.
- One more.
I know what you've got
lecture. I saw you ask for it.
- So one thing that I think
is underrepresented on trash
tastes is Mecca. And I got.
- A $400 mic transformer.
- Whoa, we can, we can, we'll go Eva.
We've only got 11 Galyon,
but we didn't, we,
we never got any like Gundam
Gundam or it is a building one.
I don't think so. I, I really hope not.
Is it a building one?
- I'm buy a building. We'll open it up.
- We'll go. We're gonna,
we're gonna find out.
- It's like perfectly flat. Of course.
There's no way it would fit in that.
- Because I've seen it.
I've signed this like this.
I've seen it. I've seen the gun plot.
And normally like if it's a
building one, the back has,
you should lose the bag. I
just assume all Gundam ones.
I just, the gun flaws if this is because,
because I really wanted a
Gundam that wasn't a gun flaw,
but it was impossible to find. And I have,
I haven't actually seen
Gundam Hathaway yet,
but Allen will not shut up about it.
Alex Allen is my editor
and he's just like gone.
And the biggest Gundam
simply know he's like gone.
If you do anything, just
watch gun Gundam Hathaway.
Because actually no it is or no. Okay.
Wow. Look at that.
So Allen,
I hope I've made you proud by
buying a Gundam and actually
really nice. Apparently
Gundam Hathaway transformer.
- According to the BBC.
- Right? You were at the BBC.
This is the best.
This is the best I can't, I can't pause.
It might as well be at gunpoint.
Look, look, this, this is,
this is like a pre-bill gun plot. This is,
this is baby's first guns be the guys.
- Can build it off camera.
- Yeah.
So Alan just told me to tell
people to watch gun and mouth
away.
I've I've heard very good
things. I've actually like legit.
I've heard so many good
things about Dunham Hathaway.
So yeah, we finally have
a Mecca apart from you.
- You've heard of the foot,
but have you heard of the hand?
That's it Choto.
- Figures.
- Did you buy one more? Actually?
Oh my God.
I bought crazy diamond too.
- You know what? I respect that.
I like.
- What I like you buy off.
- God. I actually do early board too.
But they were like to.
- The.
- Bank, there were like
two high quality figures.
I go for.
- High quality. What are you saying?
God? What are you in singer?
- It's all right, Connor.
I'm here to help you with
that Jojo collection.
- Is this, is this, what is this?
Oh, this is my.
- Most expensive figure I bought. I.
- Saw this figure.
- Head shop.
- Oh my God.
How much did this cost?
Would you like to know?
- Yeah, I know how much it
costs to vastly overpay.
- I did vastly have a pay
for it, but that's all right,
because this is going to
be, that's not the point.
- The point is can go on the.
- At least this can go
on the shelf I paid.
How much did you pay for
it? I paid $990 for this.
So I better win the
most expensive figures.
- I would like to remind people,
this is a valued at $370.
- How did they get town?
Did you pay $990 for?
I don't know, but this was the
only way I was going to make,
do with my budget. So yeah, I got it.
And you know what is mad?
Cause I really like pitch up in horse.
You're right. You're right Joey, but who?
Who's the real winner here?
I think it's monarchy.
Yeah.
I love monitor. Okay.
I go there often Christmas present to you.
- Mommy. A hundred percent profit.
300%.
- Profit off of me. I hope you're happy.
I let Sydney choose a
figure. So of course, oh,
that's going to be a big mistake. Oh yeah.
Yeah. I don't know if I can show this.
Do I want to give this one out?
What from.
- Oh, I thought it was
the, the ORC porn one.
Oh my God. You scared me.
There should be a for the. Am I.
- Supposed to put this on? Yeah.
So this was $275. Am I allowed
to like break this open?
Cause I don't think we can
show it. Wouldn't buying hints.
I figures there are so many hints.
I figures that come in
boxes that are just blank.
They don't contain a picture at all.
So it's kind of a gamble to
see what kind of figure you're
going to get.
So I'm about to find out now.
Okay. No, that's that's
Sydney straight away. Recognize the us.
Unagi figure I'm going to keep this. Yeah.
That's in the plastic. Yeah.
That's really nice though.
- For sure. The patrons.
- Yeah.
I think, I think patrons
deserve the quality.
That is awesome. He's my
favorite hand-tight artist.
This is actually a
pretty good figure. Yeah.
It's a really nice figure.
- Oh wow. Yeah.
Why is your Teddy bear
being bondaged I don't know.
- What is into some.
What is this? Is this a replaceable?
What, what is that?
Let's go.
wait, wait, wait,
can you choose the thickness
that she's going to be here?
You can go.
dude. This is next level hints.
I figures man. Okay.
Here's my, here's my.
- Hold it up for the main, I mean, okay.
Don't get me wrong. It looks amazing.
It's not a thousand dollars.
- A minute. It's not a thousand dollars.
It's probably.
- Very rare. I've never seen it before.
I've never seen it before. I'm guessing.
That's why it called Surmont.
I mean it's sick and it can
go on the shelf. Thank God.
Yeah, exactly.
- It's not too big. It's not too big.
The base of as well.
- It can go on the shelf. Okay?
- Okay. Okay.
Some of, some of my, all
of Martin go on the shelf.
It just.
- Needs some.
- We just need some like black tape.
We can do like a canonically censored.
Canonically sensor snapped off.
Oh, it happened when I
took it out of the bag.
It's all right. We can, we can bond it.
Imagine if you paid 990.
I remember it saying that
this was a broken in.
One part was broken in one pot.
Oh my God. That must be
like, that's an easy,
that must be like super rare.
That's an easy fix.
What else you get? What else you got?
- Don't tell me you got one as well. God.
- I just remembered. I
just bought some other.
There's a narrative. Teddy bear.
Oh, a car Kashi.
Teddy, Teddy, Beth.
Oh, he's my favorite character dude.
Yeah. Some, some stuff I bought
just to pat out the number,
just to get as close to a question.
How much did you guys do?
Like small scale adjustments
to get to the difficult theory
about Miranda?
Rocky is that some price tags
had tax on it and some price
tags. Didn't right.
So trying to calculate if the
price you were getting was
actually like with tax without
tax was like insane. See,
because I just completely coincidentally,
I thought I was going to have
to do that when I bought my
three figures. Yeah.
But then when I calculated
everything, I literally couldn't.
It was that it was that
close. I really, yeah.
I actually like completely coincidentally,
I got insanely close to three 30 Tuesday.
I hope as closer than.
- What's your cheapest figure, by the way,
gone the peak because I've
caught even cheaper one.
Have you had.
- Actually 100 yen?
Well, you just lost the point then you've.
- Lost another point. Lost
a point to gain a point.
- That you would've lost them before.
- I was so confident that
I would get the exact amount that I
had.
- Yeah. He hasn't what, what,
what was I bought for a
hundred yen? So was 200.
No, but what was that bought for?
What challenge? Nothing.
It was, it was so that he
could get as close to it.
Don't add a point yet.
It's it's whether he close
to the number enough.
The roll man. Sure.
- Here you go. You can have.
- That one.
This is going in the background corner.
Is that what you bought.
- By a figure from a show
that you all watched?
- Oh, that was a challenge.
Right?
Nice. Ah, okay.
Well I like it because
you've bought you've you've
completed. You've completed this,
the code gas journey and you've
now found a mate for C2 when
she bought last.
- Time.
Perfect. So I can open this up.
Let's have a look at.
- I ain't even mad with this one.
- When I see nothing but
jobs here. That is a dub.
So give me a point back.
- Wow.
Is that everything you bought? Joey?
That's everything. I
only bought three things.
Oh yeah.
Because like the thing about
Mondo Horace one was a thousand
dollars to use my budget now.
That's true. I think the biggest,
the biggest difference between
this figure special and the
last figure special is that I was like,
I was like struggling to find
things to like fit the budget
that we had set because like
we could have in most of the
doors we could have bought
like the most expensive figure
there.
And a lot of the times we did
buy the most expensive figure
there within reason. Yeah.
Ooh, that looks good.
That's a nice, straight up.
- Mean with the nice jobs.
That's just a dub and
you've all seen code kiosk.
- Yeah. We love it.
Love it. Yeah.
That all right. I have one more thing.
Okay. But Connor,
I think me and you are going
to need to swap because I,
I I'm, I'm going to need,
I'm going to need the table for this Cano.
Can we swap for a second?
Let's just put it there.
Also. I want both of your
reactions at the same time.
Okay. Okay.
All right. So I've got one more surprise.
It's a bit, it's a bit out of the box.
Okay. Literally you're
telling me I could see it.
What the?
So that's the size of my girlfriend.
So I was struggling to like
fill up my budget. Right.
And monarchy had a lot of cool figures,
but nothing that really like, not,
not nothing that really
likes, you know, spoke to me.
Yeah.
I dunno. I was thinking.
- If you've got another fate figure,
I'm going to kill my way away.
- Don't don't guess what this is. Yeah.
So should we close our eyes?
I'm going to close my eyes.
- I swear to God gone.
If it's another fate one.
- Okay. Okay.
Is this what it feels like
to be a small child during
Christmas?
I'm hearing a lot of struggling. Oh.
Oh, okay.
So before you open your
eyes, I just want, I just,
I just want to put a bit
of backstory to this. Okay.
I better be quick. Okay.
So we like to on America
a lot as you, as you know,
trash tastes Potter, trash
days is on American culture.
Okay.
And so I thought instead of
on American culture for once,
why not embrace it?
Okay.
hell. What was that?
What was that?
steel brick.
And so I thought we can embrace
American culture together
for trash tastes. Okay.
So you boys can open your eyes.
What the?
God, what the?
Okay.
So this is an air soft gun,
but I did not know that
airsoft guns look like this.
This is a steel brick.
Do you want to feel this?
What the?
Oh my God. If police come,
they're going to arrest us
that are we going to get
tomorrow? Oh my God.
So for obvious reasons,
I'm not going to get out of the
box because this looks wait,
this was only 300 bucks.
I'm like, this is,
this is making me wonder what
the airsoft community is like
in Japan, because this is, well,
if a zombie apocalypse happens,
I know who I'm going to.
Like, this is the closest
thing I've oh yeah, of course.
Of course, of course.
Oh, this is not going out of the box.
Just in case anyone ever
thinks that this is anything
button, airsoft gun, but
YouTube, this is an airsoft gun.
Don't worry about it.
I think that we might have to
blow her for you probably have
to blow her freaking patrons.
Here you go. Enjoy.
Enjoy that. And so, yeah,
this is so yeah, I was like,
you know what?
Americans love gun. So let's
just buy a gun Americans more.
Do think how realistic could
you have send them all?
Like in Neanderthal, America
loved guns, love gun.
You bought this gun.
You didn't realize the
whole point of this.
What's the five figures for
the background of our set. No,
I wanted to buy to see your reaction.
I thought that was the whole
point of the feet of the
challenge.
I wanted to get a good reaction.
Where do we put actually, where
do we put, we can put this,
how do we get rid of this?
Without someone calling the police,
we can figure that out later.
Let's figure that out later.
Hello. We've had a time skip.
No. If you, if you have notice,
- I lost all my hair
from thinking so hard.
So we are recorded the previous
recording for so long that
we actually ran out of time.
So we couldn't record the
outro. And we thought, you know,
we, we thought about
having some continuity,
then Joey got his haircut. So
we were just like, I didn't,
I didn't quite think about that.
- I'm not a team player here.
- So yeah, I guess we wanted to,
I think the last thing we
wanted to do was to tally up all
the points right? Of all of the
challenges that we would do.
- Yes.
- And also do a forfeit
as well, unfortunately,
because we recorded for so long. I mean,
I think the recording's
like three hours long now or
something like that.
It's a very long episode.
So we've had to think about it
and we thought that it would
be better if we tallied up
the points on stream and we're
not just going to do that.
There are a few points
that are under contention.
Like for example--
- Still angry two weeks later.
(laughing)
- Is the character that Joey bought,
can he beat Goku?
Is it even Goku in the first place?
- How many characters in a Mogus.
(laughing)
- They are the fucking same.
I'm sure you guys will agree
with me live on the 21st.
- Yeah, we did this live.
- So what we're gonna do
is we're gonna do something similar
to what we did for our
Trash Tastes awards.
We're gonna have a bunch of categories,
some of them, which we
argued on this podcast
and some of them are
entirely new categories.
Like who'd you guys think
bought the best figure
and who'd you guys think
bought the worst figure.
Other things that we can think of
that are going to contribute
to the final score
for what we have,
and then we will be doing
our forfeit slive on stream.
- Yeah.
- Slive on stream.
- And I guess like as well,
we'll also be able to like show you guys
some of the figures
that we couldn't really
like delve upon too much
in the episode.
Otherwise, this would have
been like a five-hour episode.
So any things we missed
during this episode,
you'll be able to see it live.
And if you're watching
this episode right now,
much further in the future,
then you could probably check it out
on the After Dark channel
where we would upload all of our streams,
which is down in the description below.
So subscribe to that channel as well.
- Yes, so the stream is going
to be on the 21st of December.
- Here's the time.
- At 7:00 PM, JST. Is that
right? That's right. all right.
- Yes.
- That looks like he's
facing a deposition.
(laughing)
- I did not hit her. I did not.
- I'm just trying my best to
retain all the information
that we agreed on because
we just like started turning
on the cameras and talking
and I'm just like, wait a minute,
we didn't agree on anything.
- So you're developing
Alzheimer's mid-sentence.
21st is the day that we
agreed to do the 21st.
- It did sound a little
Christopher Walken.
(laughing)
- As live--
- Actually on the 21st, find out who won,
who's gonna eat the punishment.
Yes, eat.
Because of course spoiler in our body.
- We actually don't even
know yet by the way.
But it's gonna involve a food
and it's not gonna be
a pleasant experience.
- Yeah, I mean--
- Of course Joey don't wanna eat it.
- The scores that we got
from our individual shops
are like one screen right now.
I can't even remember what I got
because it's been like a
week since we recorded.
- Join us then we'll see
you at the live show.
What are you waiting for?
Go and get your tickets.
They're free by following
us on After Dark Twich.
- Go get your tickets?
- Follow us on the After Dark Twitch
or just Trash Taste is
known on Twitch funny enough
not After Dark.
I will see you there, we fund.
And we'll found out who does.
- Also, I thank you very
much to our Patreons
for supporting us and making
this figure video possible.
- Yeah, honestly, if it wasn't
for you guys supporting us,
we wouldn't have had a
much larger of a budget.
- The much larger budget
than we had last year.
- Same budget that we had last year.
- Literally 10 times the budgets
from one year difference.
- It's pretty ridiculous.
- Thank you very much,
you can see all the lovely
Patreons on screen right now.
- And it's so cool.
- Yeah
- Yeah.
- It's absolutely amazing.
- And again, if you'd like to see...
This guy is gonna vote the fake figure.
(laughing)
- No, get off the screen, right.
But hey, if you'd like
to support the show,
then make sure to join our Patreon,
@patreon.com/trash taste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us your names on the sub writer,
and if you had a face,
listen to us on Spotify.
Maybe not this episode,
might not be a very good Spotify episode.
But every other episode,
listen to us on Spotify.
And yeah, guys, thanks for tuning in,
and we'll see you guys in the live stream.
- Yeah.
- Should be fun. We'll go on.
- [Connor] Bye.
(upbeat music)